WELL, GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
WILL COME TO ORDER. AND TODAY,
THERE ARE 24 BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. HOWEVER, ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 252 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON
CONSENT TODAY. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
1885. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 2019.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2831. ITEM
NUMBER 13 H.R. 13 ITEM NUMBER 15
AB 2534. ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2690.
ITEM NUMBER 17 AB 2834. ITEM
NUMBER 20 AB 2936. ITEM NUMBER
22 AB 3087, IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME TODAY, WITNESSES ARE ASKED
TO LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES, TWO MINUTES EACH TO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA.
IN A TIMELY FASHION, IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM, WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE
FIRST BILL. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MURATSUCHI. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. OR, AS I LIKE TO
SAY, OHAYO DASIMA'S OHAYO
GOZAIMASU. WHAT IMPECCABLE
JAPANESE, MR. CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE, I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1825, THE
CALIFORNIA FREEDOM TO READ ACT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
NATIONAL MOVEMENT TO BAN BOOKS,
AT OUR PUBLIC LIBRARIES. AND
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO FIGHT
BACK. WE KNOW THAT, OUR FREEDOM
TO READ IS FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT, ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LIBRARY ASSOCIATION,
LAST YEAR, THERE WAS A 65%
INCREASE IN, ATTEMPTED BOOK
BANS, THE HIGHEST LEVEL EVER
RECORDED BY THE AMERICAN LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION. OF THOSE
CHALLENGES, 47% OF THE
CHALLENGES BOOK CHALLENGES, WERE
FOR TITLES REPRESENTING THE
VOICES AND LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND THE
BIPOC. THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THIS BILL WAS WRITTEN BY
LIBRARIANS AND FIRST AMENDMENT
LAWYERS, IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I'D LIKE TO. FIND MY
WITNESS LIST. MISS DURAN. YES
YOU HAVE CRYSTAL DURAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING. PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
CRYSTAL DURAN, THE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR FOR THE BELVEDERE
TIBURON LIBRARY. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION TODAY. SO AS
OUR LETTER INDICATES, CLA HAS
OFFICIALLY REMOVED ITS OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. AND
WE'RE NOW IN SUPPORT OF AB 1825,
AS AMENDED. SO AT THEIR CORE,
LIBRARY DIRECTORS AND STAFF
BELIEVE IN PROTECTING
INTELLECTUAL FREEDOM. WE SUPPORT
THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
PATRONS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
DIVERSE BODY OF MATERIALS THAT
EDUCATE, INSPIRE, INFORM AND
ENLIGHTEN. WE ARE LIBRARY
PROFESSIONALS AND WE'RE TRAINED
IN REVIEWING AND SECURING
MATERIALS THAT SUIT THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC
LIBRARIES DO NOT SUPPORT THE
BANNING OF BOOKS. WHAT WE DO
SUPPORT IS HAVING INFORMED
DECISIONS REGARDING MATERIALS IN
OUR LIBRARIES TO MEET LOCAL
COMMUNITY NEEDS. MANY LIBRARIES
HAVE INDIVIDUAL POLICIES THAT
ALLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
ENGAGE WITH US AND RAISE ISSUES
CONCERNING CERTAIN MATERIALS. WE
WORK TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONCERNS AND COMMUNICATE
THE RESPECTIVE DECISIONS AROUND
THE PLACEMENT AND THE MATERIALS
THROUGHOUT THE PUBLIC LIBRARY.
HAVING THOSE CLEAR AND DETAILED
POLICIES IN PLACE IN EVERY
PUBLIC LIBRARY IS ESSENTIAL.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE US TO
SUBMIT THOSE POLICIES TO THE
STATE LIBRARIAN. WE'LL BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL ALSO
PROTECTS LIBRARY STAFF FROM
RETALIATION FOR NOT REMOVING AN
ITEM THAT HAS NOT BEEN FIRST
BEEN VETTED THROUGH THE REVIEW
PROCESS. CLA WANTS TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF FOR THE
PRODUCTIVE NEGOTIATIONS TO DATE,
AND FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO CLA. AS A
CO-CHAIR OF THE CLA LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE, I PARTICIPATED IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND APPRECIATED
HIS THOUGHTFUL APPROACH IN
REGARD FOR THE WORK OF THE
LIBRARY COMMUNITY WHEN SHAPING
THIS BILL. FOR THESE REASONS,
CLA SUPPORTS AB 1825, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND MAKING A GRAND
ENTRANCE. IS THAT MISS VALENCIA?
WELCOME. THANK YOU. RIGHT ON
TIME. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA VALENCIA. I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1825. PUBLIC
LIBRARIES ARE A CORNERSTONE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE, REGARDLESS OF AGE,
INCOME. EXCUSE ME, EDUCATION,
RACE OR GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION HAVE
FREE AND OPEN ACCESS TO
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN
MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE IN CIVIC
LIFE. THEY ARE ALSO BOUND BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, AND WE MUST
PROTECT THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF
ACCESS TO DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
INFORMATION AT OUR PUBLIC
LIBRARIES. WE ARE VERY THANKFUL
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
FOR INTRODUCING LEGISLATION.
EXCUSE ME, THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
PUBLIC LIBRARIES FROM EXERCISING
THEIR DISCRETION TO PROCURE
CONTENT IN A MANNER THAT
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST OR
EXCLUDES MATERIALS BASED ON
SPECIFIED PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTICS, OR ON THE BASIS
THAT THE MATERIALS CONTAIN
INCLUSIVE OR AND DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES. OVER THE PAST YEAR
, MORE THAN 3000 BOOKS HAVE BEEN
BANNED IN LIBRARIES ACROSS
AMERICA. THESE BOOKS
DISPROPORTIONATELY FEATURE
STORIES ABOUT LGBTQ+ PEOPLE,
PEOPLE OF COLOR, AND
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. BOOK BANS TO THIS
EFFECT ARE NOT ONLY
DISCRIMINATORY, THEY ARE A
VIOLATION OF PEOPLE'S FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO ACCESS
INFORMATION. POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED CENSORSHIP HAS NO
PLACE IN OUR STATE. IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE SEEN SEVERAL
MUNICIPALITIES PASS LEGISLATION
TO CENSOR BOOKS. FRESNO COUNTY
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION THAT IS
INVASIVE AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
FORM OF CENSORSHIP THAT TARGETS
BOOKS BASED ON SEEMINGLY
DISFAVORED SPEECH, NAMELY
REFERENCES TO BODILY AUTONOMY
AND GENDER IDENTITY. THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD IMPOSE AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CENSORSHIP
REGIME ON PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO
ACCESS LIBRARY BOOKS AND
MATERIALS PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. I HAVE BEEN A
RESIDENT OF HUNTINGTON BEACH FOR
OVER 13 YEARS AND BEEN A PUBLIC
LIBRARY USER OF THE HUNTINGTON
BEACH PUBLIC LIBRARY AND ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC LIBRARY SINCE I
WAS A YOUNG GIRL. ALL OF US WHO
USE PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE, HAVE A
RIGHT NOT JUST TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES, BUT TO LEARN FROM A
DIVERSE RANGE OF MATERIALS,
INCLUDING LIBRARY BOOKS BY AND
ABOUT LGBTQ AND BIPOC
COMMUNITIES. WE COMMEND
LIBRARIANS AND COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE REJECTED THESE CENSORSHIP
CAMPAIGNS. WE MUST PROTECT THE
FUNDAMENTAL FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO HAVE ACCESS TO DIVERSE
AND INCLUSIVE INFORMATION AT OUR
PUBLIC LIBRARIES. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE SUPPORT AB 1825
ENERGY TO VOTE YES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOU'RE PIONEERING A
NEW LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT RUN, A
QUARTER MILE AND DELIVER A
STATEMENT, THE DUATHLON YOU DID?
WELL. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD WITH YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WELCOME. MR. PULSIFER.
CRAIG PULSIFER, ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT, MR. STEIGER. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS AND STAFF,
MITCH STEIGER WITH CFT, A UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS. ALSO IN SUPPORT
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY? SEEING
NONE, WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
DAIS, WHICH IS IMPRESSIVELY
LONELY. I APPRECIATE THE BILL.
WE DON'T WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM. AND SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
WE HAVE MULTIPLE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS GOING ON RIGHT NOW,
INCLUDING A BUDGET HEARING THAT
INCLUDES A BUNCH OF US. SO WITH
THAT, YOU KNOW, GLAD TO SEEK A
MOTION. I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU TO THE WITNESSES. WE'LL TAKE
THAT UP WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT Ó,
YOU HAVE TWO. I'M SORRY. TWO
MORE, TO YOUR NEXT BILLS. OKAY.
LET US DO THAT, YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 1917 OR 2226. YOUR
CHOICE. ALL RIGHT. I, IF I MAY,
I'D LIKE TO, TAKE UP AB 1917
FIRST. VERY GOOD. PLEASE PROCEED
. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I AM
PRESENTING AB 1917, WHICH IS, AT
ITS CORE, A COMMON SENSE GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL, IT WOULD
REQUIRE ALL SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
TO RECEIVE THE BASIC PUBLIC
EDUCATION, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
GOVERNANCE, LAW TRAINING,
INCLUDING, RESPONSIBLE FISCAL
MANAGEMENT, DURING THEIR THEIR,
THEIR TIME OF SERVICE ON THE, ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD SO THAT THEY
MAY, PROPERLY AND ETHICALLY
EXECUTE THEIR, THEIR DUTIES AS A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. I
KNOW THAT, ONE OF MY, FIRST
TRAININGS AS A NEW SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE TORRANCE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION,
MASTERS IN GOVERNANCE PROGRAM. A
GREAT PROGRAM TAUGHT ME, YOU
KNOW, THE BASICS OF MANAGING
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR BUDGETS,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS, YOU KNOW, THEY
GET ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS AND
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH THOSE
KIND OF BUDGETS, MUCH LESS
ISSUES LIKE, PUBLIC EMPLOYEE,
YOU KNOW, ISSUES, COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ETHICS, OPEN MEETING
LAWS AND SO ON. SO THIS BILL
AGAIN, IS, COMMON SENSE, GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND, HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS IS, Ó. I
THINK I HAVE MY NOTES OUT HERE,
GAIL GARBARINO MOJICA, PLASTER
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT, AND DORIS
JOHNSON, REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. AND BEFORE I
TURN IT OVER TO THE WITNESSES,
MR. CHAIR, I WANT TO BEGIN BY
COMMITTING TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND WE'LL TOUCH
ON THAT AS WE CLOSE, WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GAIL GARBARINO MOJICA,
AND I'M THE PLACER COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS, WHERE
I SERVE 16 SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
75,000 STUDENTS ACROSS OUR
COUNTY. I AM HERE TODAY AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS, AN
ASSOCIATION THAT SUPPORTS 58
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS. AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCEDES
AB 1917 EFFECTIVE GOVERNANCE AND
EFFECTIVE GOVERNANCE IS THE
CORNERSTONE UPON WHICH
SUCCESSFUL SCHOOL BOARDS BUILD
FOUNDATIONS FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE AND COMMUNITY TRUST.
BOARD MEMBERS REPRESENT THE
DIVERSE VOICES OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AND
DESERVE TO BE SUPPORTED IN THEIR
DECISION MAKING ROLES. AB 1917
GOES A LONG WAY TO PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT BECAUSE IT HELPS ENSURE
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNANCE TEAM COME TO THE
TABLE WITH FOUNDATIONAL
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
TOPICS CRITICAL TO THEIR ROLES
OPEN MEETING LAWS, SCHOOL
FINANCE PERSONNEL LAWS AND
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY LAWS. IN
THE PAST 18 YEARS THAT I HAVE
BEEN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT, I
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE COMPLEX
ISSUES SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS FACE
. I HAVE SEEN SCHOOL BOARDS
ADOPT INTERIM BUDGETS WITHOUT
CERTIFYING WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE POSITIVE, QUALIFIED OR
NEGATIVE. I HAVE SEEN SCHOOL
BOARDS NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
APPROVING COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND NECESSARY
DISCLOSURES. I HAVE SEEN SCHOOL
BOARD TRUSTEES RESIGN ABRUPTLY
WHEN IT WAS BROUGHT TO THEIR
ATTENTION THAT A PREVIOUS ACTION
VIOLATED GOVERNMENT CODE 1090,
OR THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS GO INTO
PUBLIC SERVICE FOR ALTRUISTIC
REASONS. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
SCHOOL BOARDS IN THEIR ABILITY
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS IN
THE CONTEXT OF TRANSPARENCY,
TRUST, AND GOOD GOVERNANCE AS
THEY LEAD THE WAY FOR OUR 5.5
MILLION STUDENTS, THEY SERVE
STATEWIDE. IN CLOSING, I HOPE
YOU WILL SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS BY
SUPPORTING AB 1917. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DOROTHY JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF
ACTS OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, JUST WANT TO
ECHO A FEW OF THE COMMENTS
SHARED BY MY FELLOW WITNESS, BUT
JUST HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS TO
HAVE THAT FOUNDATIONAL
KNOWLEDGE. AND MUCH LIKE CITY
COUNCILS, BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS,
SPECIAL DISTRICT DIRECTORS, LOTS
OF DIFFERENT VALUABLE EXPERIENCE
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE. BUT NOT
NECESSARILY IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND ALL THE AREAS THAT WERE
MENTIONED. SO WE THINK THIS IS A
REASONABLE REQUEST, A REASONABLE
REQUIREMENT. WE DO REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE AND JUST WANT TO MAKE A
NOTE. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
BALANCED APPROACH FOR HOW THE
TRAININGS ARE DEVELOPED AND
OFFERED. WE THINK THIS WILL HELP
WITH COMPLIANCE, MANAGE
RESOURCES AND REALLY AGAIN
MAXIMIZE BEST OUTCOMES FOR THE
BOARD. THE DISTRICT, THE COUNTY
OFFICE AND OF COURSE OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU. SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM, DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SUPPORT? I'M GOING
TO FAST FOR YOU. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION, AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU, MISS GIBBS. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE. ANY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ALSO SEEING NONE
COME BACK. Ó, PLEASE. MR.
MACHADO. GOOD MORNING. CARLOS
MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION. WE'RE A
TWEENER, WE HAVE AN OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. I DO
WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND TO
HIS STAFF FOR MEETING WITH US
AND HEARING OUR CONCERNS, AND
ALSO FOR THE LAST SET OF
AMENDMENTS, GIVEN THAT THIS IS
MODELED ON THE FPC PROCESS FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ETHNIC OR
ETHNICS, ETHICS STUDY OR ETHIC,
SORRY, ETHICS. TRAINING, AND IN
THAT SETTING, THE MATERIALS THAT
ARE DEVELOPED BY ENTITIES THAT
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE THE
TRAINING MUST CONSULT WITH THE
FPPC. THERE'S SIMILAR LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL THAT CONSULTATION
AND PRACTICE AND UNDER
REGULATIONS BY THE FPPC. WOULD
ALLOW AN ENTITY TO MEET THAT
CONSULTATION REQUIREMENT BY,
REVIEWING THE COURSE CURRICULUM.
DETAILS ON THEIR WEBSITE AND,
YOU KNOW, PROVIDING SOME OTHER,
MEASURE OF, OF REVIEW AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE NOT
NECESSARILY REQUIRING
SPECIFICALLY THAT A CONSULTATION
HAPPEN WITH THE FPPC STAFF
THAT'S PURSUANT TO REGULATIONS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THAT
INSTANCE ALSO, HAS INDICATED ON
ITS WEBSITE THAT THEY WON'T BE
PROVIDING CONSULTATION IN, IN
ANY MEANINGFUL WAY IN PERSON ON
THESE THINGS, GIVEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, DOESN'T
HAVE THE EXPERTISE THAT OTHER
AGENCIES HAVE IN SOME OF THESE
AREAS, WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
BILL BE AMENDED TO REFLECT THE
TYPE OF CONSULTATION THAT'S
PROVIDED UNDER THE FPPC ETHICS
MODEL, WITH THAT, I'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE IT BACK TO OUR, OUR
MEMBERS TO SEE IF THEY WOULD
MOVE TO A SUPPORT POSITION. BUT
AGAIN, I DO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS, HEARING OUT OUR CONCERNS ON
THIS BILL. I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU, ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? I'M SEEING NONE.
SORRY. DID YOU ASK? NO. NOT YET,
BUT I WILL. READY TO GO. COMING
BACK TO THE DAIS, COLLEAGUE. THE
SINGULAR. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR? I DO. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE THEY
BROUGHT A REALLY GOOD POINT OUT,
AS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE SCHOOL
BOARD IN OUR DISTRICT, I DID GO
THROUGH THE CSBA. TRAINING, AND
IT WAS INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND
VERY, VERY INFORMATIVE AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I OFTEN
QUESTIONED WAS, WHY WASN'T THE
MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS GOING THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM, FOR TRAINING? BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPERATIVE THAT
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER HAD ATTENDING. AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER, I WASN'T AWARE
THAT THAT TRAINING WAS
AVAILABLE. IT WAS ACTUALLY A
FELLOW BOARD MEMBER FROM A
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
BROUGHT IT TO MY ATTENTION. SO
HE DOES, AND I AND I THOUGHT
THEY HAD A GREAT, A GREAT
PROGRAM FOR TRAINING IN OUR IN
OUR REGION. SO HE MADE A REALLY
GOOD POINT. IF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
THIS TRAINING THROUGH THE CSBA,
HOW WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO ALIGN
THAT WITH YOURS? AND TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT, YOU KNOW, SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY WORKING REALLY,
REALLY WELL? ONE THING IS
HAVING, YOU KNOW, REQUIRING
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS TO ATTEND
THE SCHOOL, THE, THE, THE
TRAINING. AND ANOTHER ONE IS
CREATING A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PROGRAM OR A NEW PROGRAM FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO OR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS TO, TO PARTICIPATE
IN. SO HOW DO YOU HOW WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO WORK THAT? OKAY. IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
REPLACE SOMETHING THAT IS
ACTUALLY REALLY, REALLY
EFFECTIVE? YEAH. LET ME SHARE
SOME OF MY THOUGHTS BEFORE I,
SEE IF, OUR WITNESSES HAVE ANY,
ANY COMMENTS ON IT. ALSO BUT
WE'RE BOTH BIG FANS OF, THE
CCPA'S MASTERS IN GOVERNANCE. I
WAS TRYING TO LOOK FOR MY
CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION, AS,
EXHIBIT FOR TODAY, BUT, YOU
KNOW, I, I WOULD BE PERFECTLY
HAPPY IF IT WAS, YOU KNOW,
MODELED ON THE CCPA MASTERS IN
GOVERNANCE PROGRAM, BUT WE, YOU
KNOW, WE JUST DIDN'T WANT TO,
MANDATE ANY, ANY PARTICULAR
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW, I THINK
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOULD HAVE A
CHOICE OF, WHAT, EITHER TO
PROVIDE, DEVELOP AND PROVIDE
THEIR OWN TRAINING TO, TO TRY TO
SAVE COSTS OF CONTRACTING OUT
OR, YOU KNOW, CONTRACTING WITH
PAYING FOR THE CCPA SERVICES, TO
PROVIDE THE MASTERS IN
GOVERNANCE TO ALLOW THEIR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE MASTERS IN GOVERNANCE
PROGRAM, AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE
CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, OUR, OUR,
YOU KNOW, WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH CCPA ON, WE WILL
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP ON, YOU
KNOW, CLARIFYING THE NATURE OF
THE CONSULTATIONS WITH THE FPC,
AND WITH THE CDE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE, PROVIDE QUALITY
TRAINING FOR ALL OUR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS. WANT TO SEE IF,
YES. THANK YOU, AS SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN A COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
IN A DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT FOR
OVER 20 YEARS, I THINK WE'RE
CONFUSING WHAT THIS TRAINING IS
VERSUS MÁS CCPA'S MASTER'S IN
GOVERNANCE, WHICH IS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM. BUT IT IS A MULTIPLE
DAY, VERY LONG HOURS, YOU KNOW,
FOR 4 TO 6 HOURS, MULTIPLE DAYS
OVER THE YEAR. THIS TRAINING
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS MORE
LIKE THE ETHICS TRAINING THAT
ELECTED OFFICIALS TAKE UPON
ASSUMING OFFICE. SO BACK IN
2004, WHEN AB ONE, TWO, THREE,
FOUR WAS PASSED, IT STATED THAT
CITY COUNCILS COUNTY WIDE
ELECTED BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALL
HAD TO TAKE THE ETHICS TRAINING
EVERY TWO YEARS. THAT
LEGISLATION BACK THEN DID NOT
INCLUDE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS, SO
THAT HAS SINCE BEEN RECTIFIED
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR OR TWO,
WHICH WILL TAKE EFFECT, I
BELIEVE, IN 25, 20, 20, 25. THIS
IS IN KIND OF IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THAT TRAINING. IT WON'T BE
A MULTIPLE DAY DAYS TRAINING. IT
WILL BE PROBABLY, MANY HOURS. IT
CAN BE COMPLETED, MUCH QUICKER.
AND AS MUCH AS THE MASTERS AND
GOVERNANCE TRAINING IS HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
THAT I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
EVERY SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER TO
TAKE. I SEE THE TRAINING BEING
OFFERED BY 1917 AS THE BASIC
MINIMUM LEVEL OF UNDERSTANDING
THAT SCHOOL BOARDS NEED TO HAVE.
SO, MR. CHAIR, I HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION. PLEASE SO,
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT PROPOSING
THAT WE DO THIS IN LIEU OF THE
CCPA, BUT IN ADDITION TO I'M
SAYING THAT THE CCPA IS MORE
OPTIONAL, BUT IT'S MUCH MORE
EXPANSIVE IN TIME AND IN TOPICS.
THEY'LL TALK ABOUT GOVERNANCE,
SETTING, MISSIONS AND VISIONS,
WHICH ARE ALL GREAT HIGH QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. I SEE THIS AS
MORE OF A NUTS AND BOLTS. THIS
IS WHAT A GOVERNMENT CODE 1090
VIOLATION IS. THIS IS WHAT A
DISCLOSURE WHEN YOU SETTLE WITH
YOUR ASSOCIATIONS. THIS IS A
REQUIRED TO CLOSE DISCLOSURES.
WE HAVE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
THAT GET ELECTED IN NOVEMBER,
AND THEY TAKE OFFICE IN
DECEMBER. AND THE VERY FIRST
THING THAT THEY HAVE TO DO IS
THEY HAVE TO APPROVE A FIRST
INTERIM. AND I CAN'T TELL YOU IN
MY YEARS OF BEING A COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT, HOW MANY SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS COME TO ME AND
THEY SAID, GAIL, I WAS NOT
PREPARED TO TAKE ACTION ON SUCH
AN IMPORTANT THING. I DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT A FIRST INTERIM
WAS. SO IT'S MORE OF A NUTS AND
BOLTS. THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO
HAVE ALONGSIDE THE ETHICS
TRAINING, WHICH WILL BE
REQUIRED, I BELIEVE, NEXT YEAR.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT DOESN'T
REPLACE WHAT CCPA IS OFFERING.
IT'S JUST I SEE CCPA AS A MUCH
MORE BROAD AND EXPANSIVE AND A
BASICALLY A HIGHER QUALITY OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS CAN CAN
SEEK OPTIONALLY. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO I YOU KNOW, I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS,
SUPERINTENDENT. AND THAT GETS
DIRECTLY TO THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT YOU AND I HAVE HAD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ABOUT MY
SUGGESTION THAT TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE, THIS TRAINING TAKE
PLACE BEFORE, A NEWLY ELECTED
MEMBER TAKES OFFICE. AND I THINK
YOU'VE MADE THE POINT BETTER
THAN I COULD. IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
AND IT'S NOT INFREQUENT THAT YOU
KNOW, A NEWLY ELECTED BOARD
MEMBER HAS HAD NO PRIOR
EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC SERVICE,
AND THEY BENEFIT HUGELY FROM
THAT TRAINING. CONVERSELY, IN
THE ABSENCE OF THAT TRAINING, WE
SEE ALL MANNER OF PROBLEMS. I
KNOW, MISS JOHNSON, YOU'VE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF A BILL
THAT I THINK AROSE DIRECTLY OUT
OF THOSE ISSUES. SO DO
APPRECIATE YOU ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I AGREE WITH
YOU. I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTIONS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE
THIS, WORK FOR EVERYONE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN. IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
THIS UP WHEN WE DO HAVE ONE,
THANK YOU TO BOTH THE WITNESSES.
AND THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I'M SORRY.
WE'VE GOT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL, OKAY. I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO ASK YOU TO. OKAY? YEAH, I DO
APOLOGIZE. HE'S DOING THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS TODAY, AND HE
TOOK A BRIEF TIME OUT TO COME
TALK TO US. ALL RIGHT. WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 2316. I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE, AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB 2316 IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT SCHOOLS FROM SERVING
FOODS CONTAINING ADDITIVES
LINKED TO CANCER, DNA DAMAGE,
HYPERACTIVITY, AND
NEUROBEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS IN
CHILDREN. GIVEN THESE LONG
STANDING CONCERNS, IN 2019, THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT, KNOWN AS OHA, TO
CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT AND
THOROUGH SCIENTIFIC EXAMINATION
INTO THE IMPACT OF SYNTHETIC
FOOD DYES ON CHILDREN. IN 2021,
AFTER AN EXHAUSTIVE REVIEW
INVOLVING TOP SCIENTISTS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
OHA ISSUED A REPORT WITH CLEAR
FINDINGS MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONCLUDED,
QUOTE, THAT CONSUMPTION OF
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES CAN RESULT
IN HYPERACTIVITY AND OTHER
NEUROBEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS. IN
SOME CHILDREN, THE REPORT ALSO
FOUND THAT CURRENT FDA APPROVAL
OF SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES IS BASED
ON 35 TO 70 YEAR OLD STUDIES
THAT WERE NOT DESIGNED TO DETECT
THE TYPES OF BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN OBSERVED IN
CHILDREN, AND THAT NEWER STUDIES
INDICATE THAT CURRENT FDA
GUIDELINES MAY NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECT CHILDREN. THE
CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE HARM
CAUSED BY THESE CHEMICALS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT OF MANY
OTHER NATIONS AROUND THE WORLD,
WHICH HAVE BANNED, RESTRICTED,
OR REQUIRED THESE COLORING
AGENTS TO INCLUDE STRICT WARNING
LABELS. TO BE CLEAR, THIS BILL
WILL NOT RESULT IN A BAN ON ANY
FOODS IN CALIFORNIA. NOT NOR
WILL IT RESULT IN ANY PRODUCTS
COMING OFF THE SHELF ON THE
CONTRARY, IT WILL SIMPLY
ENCOURAGE COMPANIES TO MAKE VERY
MINOR MODIFICATIONS TO THE FOOD
SOLD IN OUR SCHOOLS TO REMOVE
THE HARMFUL CHEMICALS AND
REPLACE THEM WITH SAFER
ALTERNATIVE INGREDIENTS THAT
THEY ALREADY USE IN EUROPE AND
SO MANY OTHER NATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD, THE SIMPLE CHANGE CAN
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE,
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR STUDENTS
WHO STRUGGLE WITH ADHD AND OTHER
LEARNING ISSUES. AS ANYONE WHO
HAS WATCHED A CHILD STRUGGLE
KNOWS, IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THERAPIES AND
INTERVENTION IN THE CLASSROOM
AND THEN FEED THEM CHEMICALS AT
LUNCH THAT FURTHER EXACERBATE
THEIR CHALLENGES. FINALLY, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MORE THAN
95% OF PRODUCTS SERVED IN
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY FREE FROM
THESE CHEMICALS, AND THAT A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE, INCLUDING
RURAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED, HAVE ALREADY
STOPPED SERVING FOODS THAT
INCLUDE THESE HARMFUL ADDITIVES.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IN OPPOSITION AND ARE ACCEPTING
A DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION TO
GIVE INDUSTRY AND DISTRICTS TIME
TO COMPLY AND NEGOTIATE
CONTRACTS. THIS COMMON SENSE
MEASURE IS SPONSORED BY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND, AND
IS SUPPORTED BY DOCTORS, NURSES,
CLASSROOM TEACHERS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA, AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS THE STATE,
AS WELL AS WELL AS MORE THAN 70
PLUS COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE SCOTT
FABER, THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP, AND
KIM FRENZEL, THE DIRECTOR OF
NUTRITION SERVICES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND THANK YOU, MR.
FRENZEL. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS KIM
FRENZEL, DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2316
AND ESTABLISHING STRONG PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICIES FOR OUR 5.8
MILLION PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS.
RESEARCH CONFIRMS. AND YOU HEARD
SOME OF THIS FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL. WHEN CHILDREN HAVE
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO SCHOOL
MEALS, TO NUTRITIOUS SCHOOL
MEALS, THERE IS A CORRELATION TO
IMPROVED OVERALL HEALTH FOR LIFE
, SUCH AS FEWER CHRONIC
DISEASES, REDUCED OBESITY RATES,
REDUCED DIABETES, LESS
ABSENTEEISM IN SCHOOL, BETTER
CONCENTRATION IN SCHOOL, AND
BETTER ACADEMIC OUTCOMES SUCH AS
IMPROVED STANDARDIZED TEST
SCORES. JUST BY MAKING AVAILABLE
A WHOLESOME BREAKFAST AND LUNCH
EACH AND EVERY SCHOOL DAY. OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS,
CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED IN CDE,
HAS PROVIDED MORE THAN $750
MILLION IN STATE GRANT FUNDS TO
HELP OUR SCHOOLS BOLSTER AND
IMPROVE THEIR ABILITY TO OFFER
MORE QUALITY FOODS AND OFFER
MORE FRESHLY PREPARED, LOCALLY
SOURCED AND MINIMALLY PROCESSED
SCHOOL MEALS. WE CAN FURTHER
THIS COMMITMENT THROUGH AB 2316
AND TAKING THE NECESSARY STEPS
TO MITIGATE A CHILD'S EXPOSURE
TO CERTAIN DYES AND TITANIUM
DIOXIDE IN OUR SCHOOL MEAL
PROGRAMS. AS A FIRST STATE IN
THE NATION TO IMPLEMENT
UNIVERSAL MEALS FOR ALL STUDENTS
SERVING OVER 879 MILLION SCHOOL
MEALS ANNUALLY, WE REALLY DO
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO CREATE
GREATER ACCESS TO HEALTHY SCHOOL
MEALS FOR EVERY T-K AND 12TH
GRADE STUDENT, WHILE ELIMINATING
NUTRITION INSECURITY FOR NEARLY
60% OF OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
LIVING AT OR BELOW THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL, WE NEED TO
CONTINUE OUR COMMITMENT TO
MAKING AVAILABLE THE HEALTHIEST
SCHOOL MEALS POSSIBLE BY THIS
PHASED APPROACH OF ELIMINATING
CERTAIN DYES AND TITANIUM
DIOXIDE FROM OUR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL MEALS, I NEED WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IT AS HEALTHY FOODS
IS HEALTHY MEDICINE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2316. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU, MR. FABER. WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SCOTT FABER. BEFORE I
JOINED EWG, I WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR FEDERAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE CONSUMER BRANDS
ASSOCIATION. I'M ALSO A LAW
PROFESSOR AT GEORGETOWN LAW,
WHERE I TEACH FOOD LAW. I'D LIKE
TO MAKE QUICKLY MAKE FOUR QUICK
POINTS. ONE IS THE OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THESE DYES
ARE MAKING IT HARDER FOR SOME OF
OUR KIDS TO LEARN, WHICH IS
UNPRECEDENTED. STUDY LOOKED AT
HUMAN EVIDENCE OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN KIDS EAT DYES, AS WELL AS
ANIMAL STUDIES SHOWING WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEIR BRAINS AND
CALIFORNIA STATE SCIENTISTS
CONCLUSIVELY DETERMINED THAT
SOME KIDS SUFFER FROM THE
BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS OF THESE
DYES, AND THAT THESE DYES ARE
CHANGING, NOT JUST THE STRUCTURE
OF THEIR BRAINS, BUT HOW THEIR
BRAINS TRANSMIT SIGNALS. TWO THE
FDA HAS NOT REVIEWED THESE DYES
SINCE THE 1960S. 70S AND 80S
LONG BEFORE TOXICOLOGICAL
STUDIES COULD DETECT THE EFFECTS
OF BEHAVIOR ON OUR KIDS BRAINS
AND MEETINGS HELD BY THE FDA IN
2011, OF THE FDA'S FOOD ADVISORY
COUNCIL, AND IN 2019 OF THE FDA
SCIENCE BOARD WERE MEETINGS OF
PROFESSIONALS. THEY WERE NOT THE
SORT OF THOROUGH REVIEWS THAT
AGENCIES CONDUCT WHEN DECIDING
WHETHER CHEMICALS ARE SAFE.
THREE OUR SCHOOLS FOOD SCHOOL
PROFESSIONALS WILL HAVE MANY
OPTIONS IF AB 2316 WERE TO
BECOME LAW, ONLY 4% OF THE
11,000 FOODS SOLD ON THE TRAY
AND ONLY 3% OF FOODS SOLD A LA
CART, AND NONE OF THE COMMODITY
FOODS PROVIDED BY USDA FOR THE
UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR HAVE THESE
COLORS OR TITANIUM DIOXIDE. ONLY
ONE OUT OF 700 DAIRY PRODUCTS
OFFERED IN SCHOOLS HAS TITANIUM
DIOXIDE ON THE LABEL, AND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
MENTIONED, FOOD COMPANIES CAN
AND DO QUICKLY REFORMULATE TO
ELIMINATE THESE SORTS OF
CHEMICALS. WHEN OTHER COUNTRIES
REQUIRED A WARNING ON FOODS FOR
THESE SYNTHETIC DYES, COMPANIES
QUICKLY REPLACED THE SYNTHETIC
COLORS IN AMERICAN FROOT LOOPS
WITH NATURAL COLORS, AS IS IN
CANADIAN FROOT LOOPS. JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE, THE LAST POINT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE IS THAT DESPITE THE
HARMS DESCRIBED BY THE OHA
REPORT, FDA HAS NO PLANS TO
RECONSIDER THE SAFETY OF THESE
CHEMICALS AND IS NOT REQUIRED TO
DO SO. THE FDA DOES NOT HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE FOOD SAFETY
SYSTEM, FOOD SAFETY SYSTEM. IN
FACT, 99% OF THE NEW CHEMICALS
THAT ARE ADDED TO FOOD SINCE
2020 SORRY, SINCE 2000 WERE
REVIEWED NOT BY FDA, BUT BY THE
CHEMICAL COMPANIES. SO LET'S DO
WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR KIDS, FOR
OUR PARENTS, FOR OUR TEACHERS,
AND ELIMINATE THESE SYNTHETIC
COLORS AND TITANIUM DIOXIDE FROM
FOODS OFFERED AT SCHOOL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
THINK WHAT EVERYBODY'S WONDERING
IS, ARE YOU GOING TO HAND OUT
THE NEW ONE OR THE, THE OLD BOX
OF FROOT LOOPS FOR ALL OF US TO
SHARE? ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. DAVID
BOLLAG REPRESENTING THE SFE
ALLIANCE, INFORMED ALHAMBRA AND
THE NEIGHBORS OF THE 40TH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR SANE
LEGISLATION. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS SANE AND NECESSARY
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI, NATALIE. MAX
ON BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CELESTE WICKS WITH
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT.
ALSO SUPPORTING NORTH EQUITY
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE. FACTS. GRANDPARENTS IN
ACTION AND THE CENTERS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. CHRIS
MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HELLO, SAM NASH, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. PATRICIA
RUCKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WELCOME, SIR
. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. ANDREW
ANTOHI, ON BEHALF OF FOOD SAFE,
LLC AND ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE
OF CAT TAYLOR. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. STACY
REARDON WITH THE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH EQUITY COALITION IN
SUPPORT. AND THANK THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
KAREN AMIGONE, ON BEHALF OF A
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY, STAND
UP CALIFORNIA. AND AS A MOM, WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, TIFFANY
MOORLACH, ON BEHALF OF CFT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
MARISSA VISMARA. ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND, PROUD
CO-SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
CHRISTINE ZELLER. I'M WITH EAT
REAL PUBLIC HEALTH NONPROFIT
THAT SUPPORTS SCHOOLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION TO
SERVE HIGHER QUALITY AND MORE
NUTRITIOUS FOOD. I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT. I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT AS
A MOM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
LEILANI AGUINALDO, ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF A FEW ASSOCIATIONS, THE CLEAN
WATER ACTION CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION, THE
SOCIAL ECOEDUCATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. SUSAN LITTLE
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. BUT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND CENTER FOR COMMUNITY ACTION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE, LET'S NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
. WELCOME, GENTLEMEN AND LADY.
YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, PLEASE. WELL, IF
YOU FOLKS WOULD SCOOT THAT WAY.
JUST. JUST ONE. OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME NOT YET. WE'RE ON. I
DON'T KNOW, MR. CHAIR. YES?
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. JOHN HEWITT, ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER BRANDS
ASSOCIATION, I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THE AUTHOR AND
THANK MR. GABRIEL FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND
DIALOG TO US AND IN FRONT OF US
TODAY. JUST A COUPLE POINTS, ON,
ON REBUTTAL, IF I WILL. I'M NOT
GOING TO DELVE INTO THE REAMS OF
REPORTS OF SCIENCE ON ONE SIDE
OR SCIENCE ON THE OTHER. I WILL
JUST TOUCH QUICKLY ON THE OHA
REPORT, SINCE MUCH FOCUS HAS
BEEN MADE OF THAT LATELY, THE
OHA REPORT AND SUBSEQUENTLY THE
MILLER REVIEW. THAT THAT
FOLLOWED UP ON THE OHA REPORT
FAILED TO ESTABLISH ANY
CAUSATION. THERE WAS SOME
CORRELATION THAT WAS INDICATED
IN THAT YOU LOOK AT THE 2021
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
. IT LAID IT OUT PRETTY, PRETTY
THOROUGHLY. I WON'T I WON'T GO
BACK AND REREAD AND REVIEW THAT
I JUST I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT FOR THE COMMITTEE'S BENEFIT
HERE TODAY, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SEVERE LIMITATIONS IN THE
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES SUMMARIZED BY
OHA, YOU KNOW, MOST NOTABLY,
THERE'S ONE QUOTE THAT STANDS
OUT THAT, YES, THERE IS A NEED
TO REEVALUATE EXPOSURE IN
CHILDREN AND FOR ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH TO PROVIDE A MORE
COMPLETE DATABASE, YOU KNOW,
FOR, FOR ESTABLISHING,
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. BUT AGAIN,
THERE THERE ARE THERE ARE NO
SOURCES OR ACTUAL REFERENCES TO
CAUSATION. CORRELATION IS ABOUT
AS FAR AS IT GOES WITH RESPECTS
TO THE OHA REPORT. BUT AGAIN, I
DIDN'T WANT TO I DIDN'T WANT TO
GET INTO A, YOU KNOW, THIS
SCIENCE VERSUS THAT SCIENCE. I
THINK THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR CHILDREN IS
A GOOD ONE TO HAVE. AND AGAIN,
APPRECIATE THE MEMBER BRINGING
THIS TO, TO THE FOREFRONT, WITH
RESPECT TO THE POLICY ITSELF, I
THINK THERE IS A THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A CLEAN AND
CLEAR DELINEATION AND
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE PROVIDES, THE STATE DOES
PROVIDE TWO MEALS TO ALL
STUDENTS. PER DAY. I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT POLICY. IT'S ONE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED POST COVID,
COMMEND THE STATE FOR DOING
THAT, YOU KNOW, AND WITH RESPECT
TO THE TRAY AND THOSE MEALS THAT
WE PROVIDE TO THE STUDENTS, IF
WE LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
APPLY THIS POLICY TO THE TRAY, I
THINK THAT'S A FAIR DISCUSSION
TO HAVE, I KNOW THAT THAT WE'VE
HAD THAT WITH, WITH, WITH THE
MEMBER'S OFFICE, BUT I THINK
THERE IS A DISTINCTION WHEN WE
LOOK AT ALL THE CART COMPETITIVE
ADULT SALES, VENDING, ASP
OPPORTUNITIES, THINGS LIKE THAT,
THAT ARE ON CAMPUS WHERE THERE,
THERE IS ACTUAL CHOICE AND
PARENTS PROVIDE MONEY TO KIDS OR
, OR OR KIDS MAKE YOU KNOW, THE
CHOICES BASED ON WHAT THEIR
PARENTS HAVE PROVIDED THEM WITH
RESPECTS TO THOSE, THERE'S ALSO,
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, MY DAUGHTER
HAD AN IEP AT SCHOOL. SHE SHE
DID NOT HAVE A FOOD, DESIGNATION
ON THE IEPS, BUT THOSE THOSE ARE
OFTEN INCLUDED IN THERE AS WELL.
SO AGAIN, I THINK THERE'S A
CLEAN, CLEAR AND CLEAN
DISTINCTION THAT CAN BE MADE
ABOUT THE TRAY, IF YOU WILL, THE
US OR THE STATE PROVIDED MEALS.
AND THEN THOSE DISCRETIONARY
FOODS THAT STUDENTS CAN CAN BUY.
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO TALK
TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT WHERE THAT
DELINEATION AND THAT DISTINCTION
CAN BE MADE, BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH RESPECTS TO THAT. I
WILL, RESERVE THE REST OF MY
TIME FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
COMMITTEE OR THE AUTHOR MAY HAVE
. THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, DENNIS, I'LL BE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION. I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE JUST BECAUSE I GOT SOME
INFORMATION FROM SOME OF THE
OFFICES. WHAT, IF YOU WANT
AMENDMENTS, HE'S TAKEN JUST
WHATEVER AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY TAKEN AS A JUST IN THE,
IN THE ANALYSIS OR WAS THERE
ADDITIONAL ONES TODAY? I'D HEARD
SOME STUFF FROM DIFFERENT
OFFICES TODAY BEING I'M NOT SURE
I'M NOT SURE. SO, BUT IT'S ONLY
IT'S ONLY WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
ANALYSIS. OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
GABRIEL. CORRECT. CORRECT,
CORRECT. OKAY. THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE WE STAND RIGHT NOW. SOUNDS
GREAT, ALL I WAS GOING TO SAY IS
THAT THERE IS A HUGE POLICY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE, THE FOOD
THAT'S PROVIDED BY THE STATE AND
THE COMPETITIVE FOODS AND THOSE
COMPETITIVE FOODS IS MR, HEWITT
MENTIONED, ARE ALSO AVAILABLE TO
STAFF MEMBERS TO THAT. AND THAT
MONEY IN THE FUNDS THAT ARE
PRODUCED BY THAT HELPS SUBSIDIZE
THE DEFICIENCY THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE NUTRITION PROGRAM. AND SO AS
WE RESTRAIN, THE COMPETITIVE
SALES, WE COULD BE IMPACTING AND
WILL LIKELY BE IMPACTING THE
SUBSIDIES FOR THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAM. AND SO THAT'S
A REAL EDUCATION DISCUSSION AND
ONE THAT I THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO FURTHER EXPLORE
TODAY. THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU,
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
MR. GREGORY. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. ADAM WRIGLEY, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
PETER CARLSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CONFECTIONERS
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. MARGIE
LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS. DEAN TALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, AUDRA HARTMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MIKE VILLINES ON BEHALF
OF DAIRY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN OPPOSITION,
TRYING TO STILL FOCUS ON
TITANIUM DIOXIDE. THANKS OKAY.
THANK YOU. ANY TWEENERS. SEEING
NO TWEENERS, THIS SEEMED LIKE A
BILL THAT MIGHT HAVE SOME
TWEENERS, LET'S COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS FOR MR. GABRIEL.
SENATOR COBURN, THANK YOU. OKAY,
SO THIS WAS A THIS WAS A VERY
INTERESTING BILL FOR ME, FULL
DISCLOSURE, I WAS THE KIND OF
MOM WHO BOUGHT EVERYTHING
ORGANIC AS MUCH AS I COULD WAS
THE KIND OF MOM WHO, AVOIDED
ANYTHING ARTIFICIAL AND DID NOT
GIVE MY CHILDREN ANY SUGAR FOR
THEIR FIRST YEAR OF LIFE. SO
THIS IS WHERE I WAS VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS. THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. SO I WAS
READING THOROUGHLY ON IT, AND I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS
TO I WAS FOCUSING ON THE LETTERS
THAT WE RECEIVED. BOTH FROM THE,
THE COALITIONS FOR PRO AND
AGAINST IT. AND HERE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE, BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S REALLY INTERESTING TO
DISCUSS THIS. WHEN I READ THE
LETTER OF SUPPORT, I WAS READING
AND I WAS, AND PER THE CHAIR, HE
COULD DECIDE WHO HE WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER THIS, BUT, ACCORDING
TO THIS PARAGRAPH, IT SAID THE
RESEARCHERS ALSO FOUND THAT THE
FDA ACCEPTABLE DAILY INTAKES FOR
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES ARE BASED ON
A 35 TO 70 YEAR OLD STUDIES THAT
WERE NOT DESIGNED TO DETECT THE
TYPES OF BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN OBSERVED, WHICH WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. COMPARISONS
WITH NEWER STUDIES INDICATE THAT
THE CURRENT AMOUNTS MAY NOT
ADEQUATELY PROTECT CHILDREN FROM
BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS. FOR SOME
DYES, THESE COMPARES INDICATE
THAT UPDATED LEVELS WOULD BE DOESN'T STATE WHICH
ONES. IT ALSO GOT THE HIGHEST
EXPOSURE FOR MULTIPLE DYES. THE
HIGHEST EXPOSURES ARE FOUND IN
JUICE AND DRINK SOFT DRINKS,
ALSO THEY HIGHLIGHT NUMBER, RED
NUMBER THREE. IT SAID THAT IF
REVISED, ADIS WERE TO BE BASED
ON NEWER STUDIES, COMMON
EXPOSURE TO FOOD DYES AND FOODS
WOULD EXCEED THE REVISED
GUIDANCE. SO FOR THE PUBLIC WHO
HAS NOT READ THE LETTER, THIS IS
ON BEHALF OF THE REPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY'S OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT, IT WAS WITHIN THAT
CAPACITY BY OUR, UNIVERSITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO THESE ARE
STUDIES THAT WERE DONE HERE.
NOW, WHEN I WENT BACK AND
STUDIED THE LETTER IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS PARTICULAR BILL, THE
THESE WERE FOUND, IT CHALLENGED
IT AND SAID THAT THE FDA, IN
FACT, HAS REVIEWED, THE FDA AND
THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
ORGANIZATION, THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION HAVE REVIEWED THESE
PARTICULAR SUBSTANCES. BLUE 1 IN
2011, 2019. BLUE TWO, 20 1119,
GREEN THREE, RED 40, YELLOW
FIVE, AND YELLOW SIX. ALL BOTH
ALL 2011 AND 2019 AND TITANIUM
DIOXIDE WAS REVIEWED IN 2024. SO
MY QUESTION HERE, AND I WAS
TRYING TO, YOU KNOW, AS SOMEONE
WHO'S TRYING TO LEGISLATE, MAKE
A DECISION BASED ON DATA AND
SCIENCE, IT WAS VERY CONFUSING
TO HAVE ONE REPORT STATING THAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE THESE STUDIES
IN, YOU KNOW, 35 TO 70 YEARS AND
HAVING ANOTHER ONE STATING THAT
THESE PARTICULAR GROUPS HAVE
DONE STUDIES IN 2011 AND 2019.
SO, YOU KNOW, AS SOMEONE WHO'S
TRYING TO BE RESPONSIBLE IS
TRYING TO BE, YOU KNOW, ONE
THING IS HAVING A CHOICE AS A
PARENT SAYING, OKAY, I CHOOSE
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
I'VE READ, NOT TO DO THIS, BUT
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE LAW
BASED ON SCIENCE AND DATA, YOU
KNOW, AND YOU HAVE TWO
CONFLICTING, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
THEN WE HAVE GROUPS, THAT
LITERALLY WORLDWIDE GROUPS, NEW
ZEALAND, CANADA, WHAT'S THE
OTHER COUNTRY THAT I READ, ON
HERE? SO I WAS DOING MY HOMEWORK
, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE THE UK, WE
HAVE CANADA, WE HAVE NEW
ZEALAND, WE HAVE THE US ALL
STATING THAT THEY HAVE UPDATED
STUDIES ON THE U.S WHO ARE WE TO
TAKE PRECEDENCE ON AND, AND
REALLY HAVE THAT CREDIBILITY
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT
SCIENTIFIC GROUPS AND IT MAKES
ME FEEL LIKE THIS IS HOW I FEEL
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE. OR, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE AREAS THAT ARE
SCIENCE DATA. THIS IS WHY I'M SO
FOCUSED ON EDUCATION CENTER AND
HUMAN ON, YOU KNOW, ON MATH AND
SCIENCE AND ENSURING THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE, YOU KNOW, THE UP
TO DATE EDUCATION. BECAUSE I, AS
A LEGISLATOR, PASSIONATE ABOUT
HEALTH AND SO FORTH, WE'RE
COMING UP WITH DIFFERENT
SCIENTIFIC GROUPS, LITERALLY
UPDATED SCIENTIFIC DATA STATING
THE OPPOSING PERSPECTIVE. LET'S
HAVE LET'S HAVE THE AUTHOR
ANSWER THIS. I THINK IT GETS TO
YOUR BROADER KIND OF CONTEXT AND
PERSPECTIVE. YEAH. AND THANK
YOU. AND I THINK, FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR PUTTING
SO MUCH TIME AND ATTENTION INTO
THIS. I KNOW HOW VALUABLE
EVERYBODY'S TIME IS RIGHT NOW.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH HERE, I
THINK JUST TO BE VERY CANDID AND
I SAY THIS RESPECTFULLY, THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF MIXING AND
MATCHING IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS CITING. RIGHT. AND
SO, THEY'RE TAKING SOME STUDIES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WHETHER
SHOULD TITANIUM DIOXIDE BE
BANNED IN ALL FOODS, AS IT IS IN
THE EUROPEAN UNION AND IS NOT IN
OTHER COUNTRIES? WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO BAN IT IN ALL FOODS
SERVED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE SAYING IT
SHOULD NOT BE SERVED IN OUR
SCHOOLS, AND THE EUROPEAN UNION
HAS PROHIBITED, I THINK IT'S
GREEN, GREEN THREE AND TITANIUM
DIOXIDE FROM ALL FOODS IN
EUROPE. SO IF YOU WENT TO ANY OF
THE 27 NATIONS IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION, YOU COULD NOT FIND A
PRODUCT WITH THAT DYE. YOU COULD
NOT FIND A PRODUCT WITH TITANIUM
DIOXIDE. AND THEY HAVE ALSO
TAKEN THAT ADDITIONAL STEP, AS
WE DISCUSSED, OF REQUIRING A
WARNING LABEL THAT SAYS
LITERALLY SAYS YOU KNOW, THIS
PRODUCT CAN HARM YOUR KIDS ON
FOODS THAT INCLUDE THESE OTHER
DYES. SO THEY HAVE LOOKED AT THE
SCIENCE AND TAKEN AND TAKEN
THESE STEPS. AND THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE PROVIDING THOSE WARNING
LABELS, LABELS. I THINK WHAT WE
DID HERE IS IT, YOU KNOW, PART
OF THE REASON THAT THEY DID THIS
RESEARCH IS THERE WAS A LOT OF
THIS CONVERSATION HAPPENING IN
THE LEGISLATURE. I THINK A LOT
OF IT ACTUALLY, BEFORE I WAS
HERE AND THERE WAS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN GROUPS WHO SAID,
NO, THIS IS HARMFUL TO KIDS. NO,
IT'S NOT. AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
SAID, LET'S PUT SOME MONEY IN
THE BUDGET. LET'S ASK AN
INDEPENDENT REFEREE TO LOOK AT
THIS, THAT WE TRUST THAT DOESN'T
HAVE ANY SKIN IN THE GAME, THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY MONEY TO MAKE.
LET'S ASK OUR STATE SCIENTISTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO DO THAT
REVIEW. AND, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
TALK ABOUT THEY WE TALKED ABOUT
THEIR REPORT WAS THE PRODUCT OF
TWO YEAR MULTIFACETED EVALUATION
. THEY EXTENSIVELY REVIEWED
EXISTING STUDIES OF THE EFFECTS
OF THESE DYES ON BOTH HUMANS AND
ANIMALS. THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
STUDIES. THESE STUDIES
DEMONSTRATE CLEARLY THAT SOME
CHILDREN ARE LIKELY TO BE MORE
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY SYNTHETIC
FOOD DYES. THAT'S THE HUMAN
STUDIES. AND ANIMAL STUDIES
INDICATE THAT SYNTHETIC FOOD
DYES AFFECT ACTIVITY. MEMORY AND
LEARNING CAUSE CHANGES IN
NEUROTRANSMITTERS IN THE BRAIN,
AND CAUSE MICROSCOPIC CHANGES IN
BRAIN STRUCTURE. SO THEY WENT
BACK AND LOOKED AT ALL OF THE
STUDIES AND I AND YOU KNOW, IF
YOU'LL YOU'LL ALLOW ME, MAYBE
WE'LL BRING MR. FABER INTO THE
CONVERSATION. HE USED TO
ACTUALLY HAVE MR. ALBION'S JOB
REPRESENTING THE FOOD INDUSTRY,
AND TOLD ME AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS, THE INDUSTRY STRATEGY HERE
WILL BE TO PICK AND CHOOSE
DIFFERENT LINES FROM DIFFERENT
STUDIES AND TRY TO WEAVE THEM
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT CREATES A
DIFFERENT NARRATIVE. BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT WE HAVE ASKED OUR
STATE SCIENTISTS TO DO, AND THEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS, THEY THEY
CONDUCTED A TWO DAY SCIENTIFIC
SYMPOSIUM TO DISCUSS TO FOSTER,
TO FOSTER DISCUSSION AMONG
RESEARCHERS AND ACADEMIA, IN
INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT. AND
THEN THEY SENT A DRAFT VERSION
OF THE REPORT FOR COMMENT BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
EXTERNAL PEER REVIEW BY EXPERTS
IDENTIFIED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. SO THIS WAS A VERY
THOROUGH, VERY COMPREHENSIVE
LOOK AT ALL OF THE STUDIES
INVOLVING HUMANS, ALL OF THE
STUDIES INVOLVING ANIMALS, FOLKS
IN INDUSTRY WERE BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE. FOLKS IN GOVERNMENT WERE
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE.
INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC EXPERTS,
THE BEST IN THE WORLD WERE CAME
TO THE TABLE AND THEY REACHED A
VERY CLEAR AND FIRM CONCLUSION
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS HAS AN
IMPACT ON AT LEAST SOME OF OUR
CHILDREN, AND THAT IMPACT IS
THAT IT INTERFERES WITH THEIR
ABILITY TO LEARN. SO I THINK WE
ARE VERY COMFORTABLE HERE IN THE
BASIS OF THE SCIENCE THAT WE
HAVE. I WILL SAY, ONE THING IS
IF YOU TAKE A STEP BACK AND EVEN
IF YOU ACCEPT EVERY SINGLE
ARGUMENT THAT THE OPPOSITION
MAKES AND WE DON'T, WE CONTEST
THAT. BUT EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT
EVERY ARGUMENT THAT THEY MAKE,
THEIR ARGUMENT IS THE SCIENCE IS
MIXED ON WHETHER THESE CHEMICALS
HARM CHILDREN. AND MY
PERSPECTIVE OF THAT IS IF THE
SCIENCE IS MIXED AND WE KNOW
ALSO THAT THESE ARE NOT
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS, THEY CAN
MAKE EVERY SINGLE PRODUCT
WITHOUT THESE INGREDIENTS. WHY
WOULD WE NOT TAKE THAT LITTLE
EXTRA STEP TO BE PROTECTIVE OF
OUR CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 3 TO 4% OF
PRODUCTS SERVED AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE GIVING THEM THREE
YEARS TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES. SO
TO ME, IT'S EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT
EVERY ARGUMENT THAT THEY MAKE,
EVEN IF YOU AGREE WITH THEM THAT
THE SCIENCE IS MIXED, I WOULD
SAY, WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT, GIVEN
THE MINIMAL BURDEN ON INDUSTRY
HERE, I THINK WE CAN TAKE THAT
EXTRA STEP TO PROTECT OUR AND TO
THAT POINT, IN ADDITION TO THE
EXTENDED TIMELINE, YOU'VE ALSO
ALLOWED FOR THE EXEMPTION FOR
COMMODITIES, CORRECT? OKAY. OR
COMMODITY FOODS. CORRECT. RIGHT.
OKAY. AND THEN I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S CLEARLY REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS, BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. YES SIR. MR. MR.
CHAIR, IF WE MAY JUST A SECOND
ON I HAD JUST A COUPLE LESS THAN
A MINUTE OF COMMENTS, BUT I DID
WANT TO JUST ASK ABOUT THE I DID
REVIEW THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WASN'T COMPLETELY CLEAR TO ME
WHAT THE EXEMPTION FOR COMMODITY
FOODS WAS. IF, MR. CHAIR, IF I
MAY ASK, THIS IS THE EASIEST WAY
TO NAIL THIS DOWN AND LET THE
AUTHORS SPEAK TO IT. AND WE'LL
CLARIFY IF NECESSARY. GO AHEAD.
YEAH. SO I SEE I MEAN WHAT'S
WHAT'S LISTED ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE ARE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE I BELIEVE
WE'VE AGREED ON DECEMBER 31ST OF
2027. SO A FULL THREE YEAR
DELAY, WHICH I THINK IS ACTUALLY
MORE THAN WHAT WHAT WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT IN SOME CASES WITH
OPPOSITIONS, WE'RE GIVING THEM
MORE TIME TO REFORMULATE THAN
THE CONVERSATIONS. AND THEN IT
SAYS AN EXCEPTION FOR YOU, THE
USDA FOOD PROGRAM. I THINK THAT
WAS TALKING ABOUT TITANIUM
DIOXIDE THAT MIGHT APPEAR IN
DAIRY AS YOU HEARD FROM MR.
FABER, THEY IDENTIFIED ONE OF
700 FOODS THAT HAVE TITANIUM
DIOXIDE. SO WE'LL HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT EXEMPTION. AND I
WAS LED TO BELIEVE THAT WAS
PIZZA. PIZZA. I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S TRUE. AND YOU HAD ANOTHER
COMMENT, MR. FABER, I JUST
WANTED TO RESPOND TO YOUR
COMMENT. SENATOR BECAUSE, THE
I'M NOT SURE, YOUR HONOR. OH,
SORRY. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW?
THANK YOU. YEAH. SO. SO FIRST OF
ALL, THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE TO DIG INTO THIS
ISSUE. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND, WHEN I ALSO TEACH CHEMICAL
SAFETY LAW AT GEORGETOWN LAW
SCHOOL AND, AND WHEN OUR
GOVERNMENT, WHETHER IT'S THE
STATE GOVERNMENT OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, ASKS, IS A CHEMICAL
SAFE, WE LOOK AT ALL THE WAYS
THAT A CHEMICAL CAN HARM THE
BODY, AS WELL AS ALL THE WAYS
THAT WE MIGHT BE EXPOSED TO THAT
PARTICULAR CHEMICAL. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID IN THIS STUDY. THEY
LOOKED AT ALL THE CLINICAL
STUDIES, 27 DIFFERENT CLINICAL
DOUBLE BLIND CROSSOVER STUDIES
THAT LOOKED AT HOW KIDS RESPOND
WHEN THEY ARE FED THESE DYES AS
WELL AS MANY HUNDREDS OF ANIMAL
STUDIES AND IN VITRO STUDIES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE CHEMICALS
IMPACT OUR BODIES. AND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL SAID,
THESE THE SCIENTISTS FOUND THAT
THESE STUDIES NOT ONLY CHANGE
OUR BRAINS PHYSICALLY, BUT
INTERFERE WITH THE
NEUROTRANSMITTERS IN OUR BRAINS
IN WAYS THAT MAKE KIDS LESS
LIKELY TO BE ATTENTIVE TO
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
HYPERACTIVITY. BUT THE OTHER
THING TO YOUR POINT THAT WE
LOOKED AT WAS HOW MUCH MORE
WE'RE BEING EXPOSED TO THESE
CHEMICALS. SO IT'S NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF THE HARM THAT IT
MIGHT CAUSE TO ONE OF OUR
ORGANS, BUT HOW OFTEN ARE IS
THAT ARE WE BEING EXPOSED TO
THAT HARM? AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS
THAT THERE'S BEEN A FIVE FOLD
INCREASE IN OUR EXPOSURE TO
THESE DYES, ESPECIALLY IN
PRODUCTS CONSUMED BY KIDS. AND
SO IF WHAT WHAT OHA DID IS WHAT
WE'D ALL HOPED FDA WOULD DO,
WHICH IS ASKED GIVEN HOW WE'RE
NOW EXPOSED TO THESE CHEMICALS
AND WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT HOW THEY
HARM OUR BRAINS, ARE KIDS MORE
LIKELY SOME KIDS LIKELY TO BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
NEUROBEHAVIORAL HARMS CAUSED BY
THESE CHEMICALS. FDA HAS NOT
DONE THAT. WHAT FDA DID WAS THEY
HELD TWO MEETINGS OF
PROFESSIONALS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION, NOT UNLIKE THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING NOW.
THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF
SYSTEMATIC, THOROUGH,
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF HAZARD
AND EXPOSURE THAT GOVERNMENTS
TYPICALLY DO WHEN THEY REGULATE
CHEMICALS. I THINK WE ALL WISH
THAT FDA WOULD DO THAT, AND AS
SOMEONE WHO SPENT HAS SPENT MANY
YEARS TRYING TO PERSUADE FDA TO
LOOK BACK AT THESE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MADE IN THE 60S AND
70S AND 80S BASED ON USING
TOXICOLOGY THAT DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE CHEMICALS
INTERFERED WITH OUR BRAINS OR
HARMED OUR BRAINS, WHICH USED AN
ESTIMATE OF EXPOSURE THAT IS
BADLY OUT OF DATE, IDEALLY, FDA
WOULD UPDATE THOSE STUDIES, BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT. I
WISH THAT WERE NOT THE CASE. SO
IT'S REALLY NOW, IN LIGHT OF
THAT, THE QUESTION IS, IS WILL
THE STATE STEP IN BASED ON THE
FACT THAT YOUR STATE SCIENTISTS
HAVE DONE THE WORK THAT WE ALL
HOPE FDA WOULD, WOULD DO? AND
CAN I JUST SAY ONE QUICK THING
ABOUT THESE OTHER GOVERNMENTS
JUST ON TITANIUM DIOXIDE? ONE
QUICK THING, BECAUSE I KNOW THE
WRAP UP HERE GO AHEAD. ONE QUICK
THING. YEAH. SO THE FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE HERE I'M HAPPY TO SIT
WITH YOU AND GO THROUGH THIS.
BUT THAT IF YOU ASSUME THAT THE
NANOPARTICLES THINK OF THEM
ALMOST LIKE LIKE MICROPLASTIC,
THE NANOPARTICLES, THE TINY
LITTLE PARTICLES THAT ARE ENTER
YOUR BODY WHEN YOU EAT TITANIUM
DIOXIDE. IF YOU ASSUME THAT
THOSE NANOPARTICLES ENTER THE
GUT AND ULTIMATELY GO THROUGH
THE MEMBRANE IN YOUR GUT AND
INTO YOUR BLOODSTREAM, AND THAT
IF YOU ASSUME THAT HAPPENS, THEN
THERE'S LOTS OF EVIDENCE THAT
THAT WILL HARM ORGANS,
ESPECIALLY THE LIVER. THE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE LOOKED AT
THIS QUESTION AND HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT TITANIUM DIOXIDE IS STILL
SAFE TO EAT, DID NOT ASSUME THAT
TITANIUM DIOXIDE, THESE TINY
LITTLE NANOPARTICLES, WOULD
ULTIMATELY GET INTO YOUR GI
TRACT AND ENTER YOUR
BLOODSTREAM. AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE.
SINCE THE EUROPEAN FOOD SAFETY
AUTHORITY, EFSA, DREW THAT
CONCLUSION, OTHER STUDIES HAVE
ALSO FOUND THAT THESE
NANOPARTICLES ENTER YOUR GUT,
ENTER YOUR BLOODSTREAM, AND CAN
HARM YOUR ORGANS, CAUSING HARM
TO YOUR DNA THAT CAN CAUSE
NEUROLOGICAL HARM, CAN CAUSE
IMMUNE SYSTEM HARM. SO THERE'S
NEW SCIENCE. SINCE THE 2022 EFSA
REVIEW THAT SUGGESTS THAT THESE
NANOPARTICLES POSE THE HARMS
THAT EFSA, THE EUROPEAN FOOD
SAFETY AUTHORITY. AND LET ME, IN
THE INTEREST OF EVENHANDEDNESS,
GIVE MR. HEWITT A CHANCE TO
RESPOND. I THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
JUST IN THE INTEREST OF TIME,
I'M NOT GOING TO DEBATE THE
SCIENCE. AS MUCH AS MR. FABER
AND I HAVE A GOOD TIME DOING
THAT, I WILL JUST FOCUS ON JUST
THREE QUICK POINTS. USDA, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION JUST
UPDATED THE SCHOOL NUTRITION
STANDARDS. THAT WAS BASED ON
CONSULTATION WITH FDA ABOUT
TOTAL DIET, ETC, THEY UPDATED IT
WITH RESPECTS TO SUGARS, SODIUM,
FATS, ETC. CALORIES. THEY CHOSE
NOT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
INGREDIENTS, COLOR, INGREDIENTS.
SECONDLY, TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT THE AUTHOR, YOU KNOW, WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
AN ON RAMP, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DEBATE THE SCIENCE. I DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT HERE, BUT WE CAN HAVE
AN ON RAMP TO ADD THESE
INGREDIENTS BACK IN BASED ON AN
FDA REVIEW. MORE THAN HAPPY TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. IF MR. FABER WANTS
FDA TO REVIEW THESE ITEMS, WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT THAT ON RAMP LOOKS LIKE TO
INCLUDE THEM BACK IN. I THINK
THAT WOULD ONLY BE FAIR. AND
THEN, THIRDLY, I THINK THERE IS
A KEY DISTINCTION AND POLICY
DISTINCTION STILL TO BE MADE
THAT, YOU KNOW, WITH RESPECT TO
THE MANDATORY MEALS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PROVIDES,
ON, ON THE TRAY, I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY A DISTINCTION ABOUT
SEPARATING THOSE OUT FROM THE
DISCRETIONARY PURCHASED ITEMS BY
ADULTS AND OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
A LA CARTE PROGRAM. SO THOSE ARE
JUST THE THREE ITEMS THAT WE'RE
STILL WILLING AND OPEN TO
DISCUSS AT THIS POINT. BUT THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR THE
ADDITIONAL APPRECIATE IT. AND I
WILL SAY OF THE AUTHOR, I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN MORE THAN SORT OF
AMENABLE TO HAVING THIS
DISCUSSIONS AS AS THE BILL HAS
MOVED FORWARD. YOU HAVE ONE MORE
THING, ONE FINAL, JUST FINAL
COMMENT. SO IN IN DEBATING AND
REALLY LOOKING INTO THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS GIVEN TO US
ON BOTH SIDES, I WAS READING,
AND I WAS LOOKING LITERALLY THE
SCIENTIFIC FINDINGS FROM THE
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
COME UP WITH THEIR THEIR
FINDINGS. I'M GOING TO BASE I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND I'M GOING TO SHARE WHY I'M
GOING TO I'M GOING TO GIVE THE,
THE WEIGHT TO OUR CALIFORNIA
SCIENTISTS AND OUR UNIVERSITIES
WHO HAVE DONE THE RESEARCH UP TO
DATE. I'M I'M HOPEFUL. I'M I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT THEY DID A, AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW HERE BASED THE
FACT THAT WE'RE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. I THINK IT IT ONLY
IT ONLY FALLS UPON US TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE USING OUR CALIFORNIA
BASED SCIENCE AND DATA THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO. SO BECAUSE OF
THAT, I'M GOING TO BUT I AM I,
I'M, I'M VERY HESITANT BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE WORLDWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ACTUALLY HAVE
DONE THEIR OWN STUDIES ARE
COMING ON THE OPPOSITE OF WHERE
WE'RE COMING FROM. SO I AM
THAT'S THE DEBATE THAT I'M
HAVING TODAY. BUT I'M GOING IN
WITH FAITH THAT THEY DID. THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENTISTS DID THEIR
RESEARCH AND THEIR WORK, AND I
RATHER I RATHER BE WRONG ON THE
SAFETY OF OUR KIDS, NOT I
APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR WILK.
THANK THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. SO
I'VE I'VE ENJOYED SPENDING TIME
WITH YOU AND BEING EDUCATED BY
YOU. AND THE ONE THING I FEEL
SAD ABOUT IS THAT MY PARENTS
HAVE PASSED BECAUSE NOW I
REALIZE I WASN'T A BAD KID. I
JUST ATE, I ATE TOO MANY
CHEETOS. WHICH I THINK PROBABLY
HAPPENS TO A LOT OF KIDS. SO SO
THE FACTS ARE THIS. THERE'S DI.
WHY IS THE DI IN THERE? THE DI
IS IN THERE FOR MARKETING. IT
HAS NO NUTRITIONAL VALUE AT ALL.
ZERO. ZILCH. SO THAT'S ONE TWO.
AS YOU SAID, EVEN IF THE SCIENCE
IS MIXED, DON'T WE WANT TO ON
THE SIDE OF THE CHILDREN? SO OF
COURSE. AND THEN I KNOW FOR ME,
JUST ANECDOTALLY, WHEN I TRAVEL
INTERNATIONALLY, I ALWAYS FEEL
BETTER THAN I DO IN AMERICA. AND
I'VE COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
IT'S THE FOOD THAT WE CONSUME.
SO WITH THAT, I'M SUPPORTING,
SUPPORTING YOU TODAY. THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION, AND FOR THE
OPPOSITION, AS THE AUTHOR
POINTED OUT, I MEAN, THERE'S A
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF FOODS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY AFFECTED BY THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION. SO HOW HOW
SHOULD WE THINK? AND ALSO
ALLOWING THAT THE AUTHORS TAKING
THE AMENDMENT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION. SO, SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU'RE OPPOSED AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EITHER 5% OR 4% OF
FOODS AVAILABLE TO CHILDREN, YOU
KNOW, HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
THAT IN A LARGER CONTEXT, MR.
CHAIR? THANK YOU. I THINK, FIRST
OF ALL, I WENT THROUGH AND READ
THE TWO DIFFERENT REPORTS THAT
CSPI HAD PUT OUT WITH RESPECT TO
THIS. I TRIED TO FIND THOSE
EXACT NUMBERS. I COULDN'T I'M
NOT GOING TO DISPUTE THAT. THERE
WAS ONE SPOT IN THERE THAT SAID
15, BUT 4, 15. LET'S JUST TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF THAT. THE
FACT OF THE MATTER REMAINS THAT
A LA CARTE ITEMS ARE USED TO
SUBSIDIZE AND HELP MAKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHOLE, THOSE ITEMS ARE
UTILIZED FOR FINANCIAL PURPOSES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
SPENDING OVER CLOSE TO $600
MILLION A YEAR, YOU KNOW, WITH
RESPECTS TO PROVIDING TWO MEALS
A DAY. THEY DO SO AT AT A LOSS
TO MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THEY
UTILIZE THE A LA CARTE ITEMS TO
BACKFILL SOME OF THOSE A LA
CARTE ITEMS, HAVE THEM HAVE
THOSE COLORS IN THERE, WE THINK
THAT THERE'S A DISTINCTION YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, A DISTINCTION TO BE
MADE, YOU KNOW, WITH RESPECT TO
THAT. SO AGAIN, WHETHER IT'S 4%
OR 15, 4% OF 500 MILLION IS 590
MILLION IS A LOT, 14% IS EVEN
MORE, BUT, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I'M
WILLING AND HAPPY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION. I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
THAT THE AUTHOR IS EQUALLY AS
EXCITED ABOUT, YOU KNOW, LOOK,
WE'LL WE'LL HAVE FDA DO THE
STUDIES, THE SENATOR MENTIONED
ABOUT GIVING DEFERENCE TO OHA.
IF FDA COMES BACK AND RE REVIEWS
THESE ITEMS AND SAYS
EVERYTHING'S FINE BASED ON SOME
INDEPENDENT CRITERION STANDARD,
THERE SHOULD BE AN ON RAMP TO
INCLUDE THESE INGREDIENTS BACK
IN INTO OUR NUTRITION PROGRAM.
OKAY, I APPRECIATE IT. I EXPECT
OKAY, PLEASE, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT REGARDING THE
COMPETITIVE FOODS AND POINT OUT
THAT IN CALIFORNIA, WE WERE THE
FIRST IN THE NATION TO TAKE
STRONG MAKE STRONG STANDARDS
AROUND THE COMPETITIVE FOODS TO
THE POINT THAT USDA ACTUALLY
FOLLOWED SUIT MANY YEARS LATER
TO SOME OF THE STANDARDS THAT WE
SET, KNOWING THAT WE WANTED TO
GET, CAFFEINE OUT OF ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS, THAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO
HAVE, SODAS AS COMPETITIVE
FOODS. SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO CONSIDER KEEPING THE
COMPETITIVE FOODS ON THE TABLE
FOR THE ELIMINATION OF THESE,
THESE ITEMS, ADDITIONALLY, WITH
THE UNIVERSAL MEALS, THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS GIVING $1.9
BILLION TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS TO
PAY THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. SO
SCHOOLS ARE IN BETTER,
FINANCIALLY, IN A BETTER PLACE.
AND MANY SCHOOLS HAVE OPTED NOT
TO DO COMPETITIVE FOODS FOR THE
VERY FACT THAT THEY WANT THE
HEALTHIEST FOODS POSSIBLE. AND
TO REALLY PROMOTE THE UNIVERSAL
MEALS THROUGH A BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH EACH DAY. I APPRECIATE
THAT, AND SO I KNOW YOU'LL TOUCH
ON MANY, IF NOT ALL, OF THESE
ISSUES IN YOUR CLOTHES. I ALSO
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT THE
BILL IS CURRENTLY, STRUCTURED,
DOES NOT INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT CORRECT. IT DOES ALL
SCHOOLS. OKAY, SO I DON'T WANT
TO BE CLEAR ON THAT VERY GOOD,
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? NO. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. I THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR. AND I
JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY, BOTH THE OPPOSITION
AND THE WITNESSES AND ALL OF THE
SENATORS FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION. I WAS GOING TO
TAKE, SENATOR WILK'S BEAUTIFUL
COMMENTS AS MY CLOSE. BUT SINCE
I'VE BEEN, ADMONISHED BY THE
CHAIR TO RESPOND, I'LL JUST MAKE
A FEW COMMENTS. ONE IS, YOU
HEARD FROM, THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FROM MISS FRIZELL,
COMPETITIVE FOODS, THE FOOD
SAFETY REGULATIONS HAVE ALWAYS
APPLIED TO BOTH FOODS ON THE
TRAY AND COMPETITIVE FOODS. SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE INDUSTRY IS
ASKING FOR HERE IS REALLY AN
UNPRECEDENTED CARVE OUT FOR A
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF CHEMICALS.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE AGREE THAT
THAT IS NOT HOW FOOD SAFETY LAW
HAS WORKED. IT IS NOT HOW WE
HAVE DONE THE WORK IN OUR
SCHOOLS. AND TO ME, THAT WOULD
BE TO SEEM TO BE A REALLY A
REALLY RADICAL DEPARTURE FROM
THE WAY THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS
WORKED TO PROTECT CHILDREN IN
OUR SCHOOLS. I WILL SAY I'M NOT
SURE I QUITE BUY THE ARGUMENT
THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW GOING TO
IMPACT THE BOTTOM LINES OF
SCHOOLS. WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE TO THAT, AND I FEEL
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT IF OUR
SCHOOLS WERE GOING TO TAKE A
FINANCIAL HIT, OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, THE PTA, AND
CERTAINLY CTA AND CSCA WOULD NOT
BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IF
THIS WAS GOING TO MEANINGFULLY
REDUCE SCHOOL BUDGETS. THERE IS
NO WAY THAT ALL OF THESE
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS, SO MANY,
SO MANY DISTRICTS, SO MANY
SUPERINTENDENTS, SO MANY SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS WOULD SUPPORT THIS
BILL. SO I DON'T ACTUALLY, I
GUESS I'M LESS I'M EXTREMELY
CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A FINANCIAL IMPACT ON, ON
OUR DISTRICTS AND DOING ALL OF
THIS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT TODAY,
BUT I DID DO A CHANCE TO TALK
WITH SOME OF YOU ABOUT WHICH I
THINK IS IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE OF THE
SCHOOL NUTRITION REQUIREMENTS
ALREADY IN LAW, MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY HAVE
ALREADY REFORMULATED AND ARE
ALREADY SELLING DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS IN OUR SCHOOLS. SO THE
BAG OF CHIPS THAT YOU BUY ACROSS
THE STREET AT THE CONVENIENCE
STORE, AND THE BAG OF CHIPS THAT
YOU BUY IN THE SCHOOL, EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY HAVE THE SAME
PACKAGING, THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE BAG OF
CHIPS AT THE CONVENIENCE STORE
DOESN'T MEET AND COMPLY WITH THE
NUTRITIONAL STANDARDS THAT ARE
PART OF LAW. SO AGAIN, I WILL
JUST I THINK SENATOR WILK SUMMED
IT UP BEAUTIFULLY, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT SOME
POTENTIAL MINOR, I WOULD ARGUE,
HYPOTHETICAL BURDEN ON INDUSTRY
OR STANDING WITH OUR KIDS,
PROTECTING OUR KIDS, PROTECTING
THE ABILITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
LEARN. AS A DAD, I'M GOING TO
STAND WITH THE KIDS EVERY SINGLE
TIME. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND AGAIN,
TO POINT OUT THAT ONE OF YOUR
AMENDMENTS INCLUDES A PROVISION
FOR SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE
MARKET TO READJUST TO THESE NEW
FORMULATIONS. AND WITH THAT, WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM. SO WE WILL
NOT TAKE A MOTION UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS WE DO. BUT I'LL SUPPORT
THE BILL WHEN WE DO. AND I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU
PROBABLY WISH THAT WERE BRIEFER,
BUT IT WAS IT WAS AT LEAST VERY
THOROUGH, AND I APOLOGIZE. I
HAVE TO GO PRESENT A BILL IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. I'M GOING TO
LEAVE THE GAVEL IN THE CAPABLE
HANDS OF MY VICE CHAIR, AND I
WILL BE BACK AS SOON AS I CAN.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
MURATSUCHI GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU.
AND YOU WILL BE DOING A BILL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 1970
17. RIGHT NO, SORRY. NUMBER SIX,
AB 2226. YES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU'RE READY? THANK YOU,
VICE CHAIR AQUEBOGUE. I'M
PRESENTING A BILL THAT IS VERY
FAMILIAR TO THIS COMMITTEE, AND
SO I WON'T, BELABOR THE POINT, A
BILL THAT WOULD MAKE
KINDERGARTEN MANDATORY, I FIRST
WANT TO THANK SENATOR RUBIO'S
LEADERSHIP ON ON THIS TOPIC. AND
SHE WAS TRYING TO MAKE IT, FOR
THE HEARING, BUT I BELIEVE SHE,
IS IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE HEARING,
BUT AS THIS COMMITTEE WELL
KNOWS, THE BIGGEST RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT AND OPPORTUNITY GAPS
, ESPECIALLY IN LOW INCOME BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES, IS
QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. WHILE WE ARE WORKING
SO HARD TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN, WE ARE MISSING
BETWEEN 4 TO 5% OF KIDS WHO ARE
NOT ENROLLING IN KINDERGARTEN.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT IS
ESPECIALLY THE CASE. THERE'S A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO KIDS THAT
ARE NOT ENROLLING IN
KINDERGARTEN. AND SO IT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT, YOU KNOW,
THAT WE JOIN 17 OTHER STATES IN
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA THAT
ALREADY REQUIRE KINDERGARTEN TO
BE MANDATORY. AND, SO I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES AND TO, EOSIMIAS WITH
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND TONY TRUJILLO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I'M
ANA ARCHIMEDES, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL 2226 TO
MAKE KINDERGARTEN A MANDATORY
GRADE LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA
STARTING IN 2026. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED VIEWS MANDATORY
KINDERGARTEN AS A KEY PIECE OF
CALIFORNIA'S VISION TO MAKE SURE
EVERY CHILD HAS THE EARLY
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES THEY NEED
TO SUCCEED. IT'S ALSO
FUNDAMENTAL TO EQUITY AND
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WE
SEE BETWEEN SOME OF OUR KIDS
COMING FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS AND THEIR CLASSMATES
AT LOS ANGELES UNIFIED, WE'VE
SEEN THAT KIDS WHO ATTEND
KINDERGARTEN DO BETTER ON THEIR
YEAR END ASSESSMENTS IN FIRST,
SECOND AND THIRD GRADE AND HAVE
HIGHER SCORES ON THEIR SMARTER
BALANCED TESTS AS LATE AS FIFTH
GRADE. THESE IMPRESSIVE RESULTS
ARE NOT UNIQUE TO LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED. RECENT RESEARCH DONE BY
EXPERTS AT UC IRVINE
DEMONSTRATED THAT CHILDREN IN
STATES WITH MANDATORY
KINDERGARTEN DO BETTER. THEY ARE
MORE LIKELY TO GO TO COLLEGE,
EARN MORE, AND ARE LESS LIKELY
TO BE POOR AS ADULTS. THESE
IMPACTS ARE STRONGEST FOR LATINO
AND BLACK CHILDREN, WHICH IS
EXACTLY THE GROUPS WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD AND MAKE SURE ALL KIDS IN
LOS ANGELES, IN CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE READY FOR THE WORLD. AS
WITH ALL OTHER MANDATORY GRADES,
THE SAME PARENTAL RIGHTS TO USE
PRIVATE SCHOOL OR HOME SCHOOL
ARE MAINTAINED WITH. WITH OUR
MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN BILL, WE
HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN
THE 17 OTHER STATES THAT
PRIORITIZE EARLY LEARNING FOR
ALL CHILDREN AND MAKE
KINDERGARTEN A MANDATORY GRADE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, TONY TRIGUERO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, A
CO-SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO,
226 AND A LONG TIME SUPPORTER OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF KINDERGARTEN,
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT,
KINDERGARTEN PROVIDES THE
BUILDING BLOCKS OF PHYSICAL,
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AS WELL AS THE BASICS OF
LANGUAGE LITERACY, THINKING,
COGNITIVE SKILLS, KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS, COOPERATION, PATIENCE,
SHARING, LISTENING, AND OTHER
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL LEARNING
SKILLS. IF A CHILD MISSES
KINDERGARTEN, THEY MISS EARLY
MILESTONES IN READING AND MATH
SKILLS, WHICH FORCES THEM TO
CONFRONT THOSE HURDLES IN THE
FIRST GRADE WITHOUT
KINDERGARTEN, CHILDREN WILL BE
FAR BEHIND THEIR PEERS WHEN
ENTERING FIRST GRADE. THE
DISPARITIES FOR STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT ATTEND KINDERGARTEN ARE NOT
ONLY PHYSICALLY VISIBLE AS IT
PERTAINS TO STUDENTS CONFIDENCE
AND PARTICIPATION IN CLASS, BUT
ALSO ACADEMICALLY MEASURABLE.
NOW, MORE THAN EVER, WE MUST
ENSURE OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
RECEIVE CRITICAL INSTRUCTION
EARLY ON TO PREPARE BOTH
SOCIALLY AND ACADEMICALLY. AND
THE BEST WAY TO SUPPORT
CLASSROOM TEACHERS IS BY HAVING
STUDENTS PREPARED IN THE
CLASSROOM AS THEY MOVE UP EACH
ACADEMIC GRADE LEVEL. WE NEED TO
GIVE EVERY CHILD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL,
AND KINDERGARTEN IS THE KEY. ON
BEHALF OF OUR 300,000 MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MA'AM. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2226 HERE IN ROOM
20, ROOM 2100. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. CASSIE MANCINI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS FAITH LEE
WITH ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
MONNING CELESTE WICKS FOR CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT ALSO
SUPPORTING NORTH COUNTY EQUITY,
JUSTICE AND ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS, THANK YOU. SIERRA COOK
WITH SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IN
SUPPORT. STELLA JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
ESPARZA NUNEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
COLLEGE-READY PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2226. YOUR NAME, SIR. GOOD
MORNING. SENATORS. IF APOLOGY,
ON BEHALF OF THE INFORMED DAVID
BALOG, ON BEHALF OF INFORMED
ALHAMBRA WITH THE BACKING OF THE
SFE ALLIANCE WITH FIVE REASONS
WHY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE NUMBER ONE, WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTION TO FURTHER EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT. WHEREAS
THE SPONSORS MOTIVATION MAY BE
TO INCREASE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AT OTHER UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND RAISE MORE UNION DUES FOR
THE CTA NUMBER TWO CHILDREN
DEVELOP AT DIFFERENT RATES,
MANDATING KINDERGARTEN IGNORES
THE NATURAL VARIABILITIES IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT.
SOME STUDENTS MAY BENEFIT FROM
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR AT HOME OR IN
A LESS STRUCTURAL EDUCATIONAL
SETTING. THE DECISION ABOUT WHEN
AND HOW A CHILD BEGINS THEIR
FORMAL EDUCATION SHOULD LARGELY
REST WITH THEIR PARENTS OR
GUARDIANS, WHO ARE MOST FAMILIAR
WITH THE CHILD'S DEVELOPMENT AND
READINESS FOR SCHOOL. NUMBER
THREE. ACCORDING TO EDUCATION
CODE 4800 KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS ARE LIMITED TO 24
STUDENTS, WITH A 12 TO 1 TEACHER
TO STUDENT RATIO. THE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER'S ASSISTANT
IS NOT ALWAYS IN THE CLASSROOM,
WHICH LEADS THE TEACHER ALONE
WITH 24 STUDENTS FOR EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME. NUMBER FOUR
CHILDREN THAT ARE MORE ACTIVE
HAVE A HARDER TIME SITTING
STILL. THIS HAS LED TO
MISDIAGNOSIS. MISDIAGNOSING
CHILDREN WITH ADHD OR ATTENTION
DEFICIT DISORDER, RESULTING IN
CHILDREN TAKING UNNEEDED
MEDICATIONS. WE ALL KNOW THESE
DRUGS ARE NOT WITHOUT THEIR
UNDESIRED SIDE EFFECTS. THESE
MIND ALTERING SUBSTANCES COULD
AND OFTEN DO, KILL THE SPIRIT OF
THE CHILD IN ORDER TO CONTROL
THEM FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
CLASSROOM. WE WOULDN'T WANT THIS
HAPPENING TO ANY CHILDREN, EVEN
YOUNGER. AND NUMBER FIVE AND MR.
MURATSUCHI OAN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT, THE PALOS VERDES
PENINSULA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT INFRASTRUCTURE IS
BECOMING MORE DILAPIDATED BY THE
DAY AND BADLY IN NEED OF
STRUCTURAL MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR. THIS HAS CAUSED THE
DISTRICT TO SHUT DOWN ONE OF ITS
SCHOOLS FOR THREE DAYS THIS
YEAR, DUE TO A LACK OF
ELECTRICAL POWER, WITH THE
CURRENT MANDATE FOR COMPULSORY
SCHOOLING, THE STATE CANNOT OR
LACKS THE WILL TO MEET ITS
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR SAFE AND ADEQUATE LEARNING
FACILITIES. THESE REASONS SHOW
THAT PARENTS SCHOOL IN THE STATE
IS NOT READY TO ADD ON MORE
FORCED SCHOOLING, DEMONSTRATING
THE BEST CHOICE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO REJECT THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2226 HERE IN ROOM 2100? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANY COMMENTS? AND
QUESTIONS BY NÓ. OKAY, WELL,
HISTORICALLY, YOU PROBABLY
ALREADY KNOW I'VE BEEN OPPOSED
TO MANDATING KINDERGARTEN. NOT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO MERIT TO IT,
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GREAT BENEFITS TO
KINDERGARTEN. OF COURSE, OUR
CHILDREN DO INCREDIBLY WELL, BUT
I ALSO BELIEVE, AS, AS A PARENT
AND AS A FORMER EDUCATOR, THAT
CHILDREN DEVELOP IN DIFFERENT
WAYS, AND ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
FIRST FIVE YEARS, THE MATURITY
IS VERY, VERY DIFFERENT FOR
MANY, MANY CHILDREN. AND I THINK
ONCE WE HAVE A MANDATE FOR A
GRADE, ESPECIALLY A BRAND NEW
GRADE, GRADE LEVEL, MAKE IT A
MANDATED. THAT MEANS THAT OUR
PARENTS DON'T HAVE AS MANY
CHOICES IN MAKING DECISIONS FOR
THEIR KIDS, BECAUSE NOW THE
STATE COMES IN AND SAYS, NOW THE
STATE HAS AUTHORITY AND
JURISDICTION OVER THOSE
CHILDREN. AND SO THAT'S WHERE I,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A, A, A CONCERN
IS THAT THOSE KIDS ARE ONLY
OURS, TRULY OURS. FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS. AND AFTER THAT,
THE SCHOOL COMES IN AND SAYS,
OKAY, THIS IS WHAT IS BEST FOR
YOUR CHILD. THIS IS WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO WITH YOUR CHILD. AND
IT IT IT, IT INFRINGES ON, ON
THE FREEDOMS OF OUR OF THE
CHOICES OF THE PARENTS. AND
THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW, I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
KINDERGARTEN, BUT I DON'T
SUPPORT MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN.
IF THE PARENT CHOOSES AND THINKS
THAT THEIR CHILD IS READY FOR
THAT GRADE AND TO COME INTO THE
CLASSROOM AND PARTICIPATE, THEN
LO AND BEHOLD, IT'S THERE, FOR
ALL OF OUR KIDS. BUT THERE ARE
SOME KIDS AND SOME PARENTS WHO
BELIEVE AND WILL, YOU KNOW, BE
UNDER THE NEW UNDERSTANDING THAT
, NO, THIS CHILD IS NOT READY TO
GO INTO KINDERGARTEN. I HAVE
PARENTS WHO HAVE PUT THEIR KIDS
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND AT SOME
POINT SEE A CHANGE IN THEIR
CHILD'S BEHAVIOR AND SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT? YOU'RE NOT READY FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO BE ON THEIR
OWN. SO WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME
HOMESCHOOLING. WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THE SCHOOLS FOR YOU. SO
THOSE ARE, YOU KNOW, OPTIONS
THAT PARENTS MAKE WHEN THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT, AND IN
THIS CASE, I WILL CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE MANDATORY
KINDERGARTEN. BUT I'M GRATEFUL
THAT WE OFFER IT AS A STATE,
THAT WE OFFER IT TO ALL OF OUR
PARENTS. AND QUITE FRANKLY, WE
ONLY HAVE WHAT, MAYBE 3 TO 5% OF
KIDS WHO ARE NOT ATTENDING,
KINDERGARTEN. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL RESPECTFULLY NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AGAIN, THIS
YEAR. AND WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. WE DON'T HAVE MANY
MEMBERS HERE. SO WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR OUR MEMBERS TO HE'S
GOING TO HAVE A CLOSE. OH, YES.
ABSOLUTELY SORRY, THOSE WERE MY
COMMENTS, BUT, YES, ABSOLUTELY.
PLEASE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VICE CHAIR.
I, AGAIN, THIS THIS COMMITTEE
HAS TAKEN UP THIS THIS, PROPOSAL
MANY TIMES WITH SENATOR RUBIO'S
LEADERSHIP, JUST TO QUICKLY
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS, VICE
CHAIR, I JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE BILL WILL
ALLOW FOR HOME SCHOOLING. IF TO
GIVE PARENTS THAT OPTION. IT
ALSO ALLOWS FOR PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR, FOR EITHER
FULL DAY OR HALF DAY A
KINDERGARTEN. AND SO I THINK
WHEN YOU BALANCE THAT WITH ALL
OF THE, YOU KNOW, THE, THE CLEAR
DATA SHOWING THE, THE LONG TERM
BENEFITS, THE, THE, THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE THOSE,
THOSE ACHIEVEMENT AND
OPPORTUNITY GAPS, ESPECIALLY,
YOU KNOW, WHERE, YOU KNOW,
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ARE PARTICIPATING IN
KINDERGARTEN AT A LOWER RATE
THAN OTHER COMMUNITIES, AND THAT
THERE IS ABUNDANT DATA SHOWING
THAT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP LARGELY
STARTS BEFORE KIDS GET TO K
THROUGH 12. AND SO, YOU KNOW WHY
? WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT TO HAVE
ALL OF OUR KIDS AT THE SAME
STARTING LINE THAT THAT IS THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERNS, RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR THE SENATORS I VOTES.
THANK YOU. MOYAMOYA. MURATSUCHI
FOR YOUR TIME. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH MEMBER MCCARTY
FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 2508.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, PRESENT TO YOU A BILL,
WITH NO OPPOSITION, UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT. SO FAR, THIS EXPANDS ON
OUR CAL KIDS PROGRAM, WHICH WAS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST WINS OF THE
PAST FEW YEARS IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHERE WE CREATED
UNIVERSAL COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS FOR KIDS WHEN THEY
ENTER KINDERGARTEN. AND THE
RESEARCH IS CLEAR. PRETTY
AMAZING THAT EVEN IF YOU HAVE
LESS THAN $500 IN YOUR NAME FOR
A COLLEGE ACCOUNT, YOU'RE MORE
THAN YOUR 25% MORE LIKELY TO GO
ON TO COLLEGE. BASICALLY
BUILDING EXPECTATIONS. COLLEGE
SHOULDN'T BE JUST ABOUT KIDS
THAT HAVE TRUST FUNDS. THIS
SHOULD BE ABOUT OFFERING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAVING EARLY
ON. SO WE CREATED THIS PROGRAM.
BUT ONE A LITTLE BIT FLAW IS
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS ARE IN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM, ARE OUR FOSTER YOUTH
STUDENTS. AND SO OF COURSE, IF
THERE'S A FOSTER YOUTH THAT THAT
STARTS AS A FOSTER YOUTH, WHEN
THEY'RE IN KINDERGARTEN, THEY'LL
ENTER THIS PROGRAM AND GET A CAL
KID ACCOUNT IN THEIR NAME.
HOWEVER, IF THEY BECOME A FOSTER
YOUTH LATER IN LIFE, LIKE SECOND
GRADE OR THIRD GRADE OR FOURTH
GRADE, THEY MISS THE BOAT. AND
THESE ARE THE KIDS THAT THAT WE
NEED THE MOST TO BE ABLE SURE TO
HAVE A SOLID EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. SO THIS WOULD
JUST EXPAND ELIGIBILITY, NO NEW
MONIES. BUT IN THE EXISTING
ALLOCATION FOR ALL KIDS WHO
ENTER THE FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM
BETWEEN FIRST AND 12TH GRADE
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO ENTER THE
CAL KIDS PROGRAM, RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE. VOTE WITH ME
TODAY. ARE THE JOHN BYRNE
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH FROM CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. WONDERFUL. WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE RAUSCHER AND I'M THE
CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER AT JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH, OR
JB. JB WAS FOUNDED BY SENATOR
JOHN BURTON AND WORKS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AMONG
ALL STUDENT GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA, FOSTER YOUTH FACED
THE GREATEST BARRIERS TO
ACHIEVING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS. ABUSE AND NEGLECT IN THE
HOME, REMOVAL FROM FAMILY, AND
FREQUENT MOVES CONTRIBUTE TO THE
POOR OUTCOMES WE SEE. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT 90% EXPRESS A
DESIRE TO ATTEND COLLEGE, THE
PERCENTAGE WHO GO ON TO EARN A 2
OR 4 YEAR DEGREE IS LESS THAN A
THIRD OF THAT FOR THE
POPULATION. MORE BROADLY,
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AND THE NEED TO
WORK IS THE PRIMARY REASON
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH CHOOSE
NOT TO ATTEND COLLEGE. THEY
SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD IT. THE CAL
KIDS PROGRAM IS POISED TO PLAY A
MAJOR ROLE IN CHANGING THESE
STATISTICS. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
CHILDREN WITH COLLEGE SAVINGS IN
THEIR NAME ARE THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO ENROLL IN
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION, AND
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
GRADUATE. ONE STUDY FOUND THAT
STUDENTS WHO HAD A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT WERE 40% LESS
LIKELY TO BE CHRONICALLY ABSENT
THAN STUDENTS WITHOUT AN
ACCOUNT. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED THIS PROGRAM, THE
INTENTION WAS TO PROVIDE
ENHANCED DEPOSITS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. HOWEVER, UNDER THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE, NEARLY HALF OF
ALL FOSTER YOUTH ARE INELIGIBLE
FOR THIS ENHANCED DEPOSIT ONLY
IF A CHILD'S FOSTER CARE
INVOLVEMENT OVERLAPPED WITH
CENSUS DAY OF THE FIRST GRADE
ARE THEY ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
BENEFIT. BUT THIS ISN'T HOW THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WORKS. ABUSE
AND NEGLECT CAN HAPPEN TO A
CHILD AT ANY AGE, AND THE STATE
BEARS RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
WELL-BEING OF ALL OF ITS
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE, NOT
JUST THOSE IN THE FIRST GRADE
FOSTER YOUTH OF ANY AGE FACE
ENORMOUS BARRIERS, AND THEY ALL
HAVE THE SAME HOPES AND DREAMS
FOR A BETTER FUTURE. AB 2508
WILL REMEDY THIS OVERSIGHT,
OPENING UP THE POSSIBILITY OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO THOUSANDS OF
FOSTER YOUTH. I RESPECTFULLY,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2508. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
WEDNESDAY POPE AND I AM A
CURRENT STUDENT AT FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE, MAJORING IN LAW AND
PUBLIC POLICY. I'LL BE
TRANSFERRING TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY THIS COMING YEAR
BECAUSE THE CAL KIDS PROGRAM
CURRENTLY ONLY APPLIES TO
STUDENTS IN FOSTER CARE IN THE
FIRST GRADE. UNFORTUNATELY,
STUDENTS LIKE ME ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS VITAL PROGRAM.
I SPENT OVER EIGHT YEARS IN AND
OUT OF FOSTER CARE, STARTING AS
A NEWBORN. HOWEVER NEVER IN
THOSE EIGHT YEARS WAS I ACTUALLY
IN FOSTER CARE. IN THE FIRST
GRADE. I AM A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT GROWING UP, I
EXPERIENCED NOT ONLY FOSTER CARE
BUT ALSO EXTREME POVERTY, AND NO
ONE EVER SPOKE TO ME ABOUT
COLLEGE AND THE BENEFITS. I
THOUGHT IT WAS SOMETHING OUT OF
REACH. I HAD HEARD THAT IT WAS
EXPENSIVE AND WOULD LEAD ME INTO
LONG TERM DEBT. AT THE AGE OF
16, I GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL
EARLY WHILE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. BY THE AGE OF 17,
DESPITE LACKING AN EMOTIONAL AND
FINANCIAL SAFETY NET, I DECIDED
TO TAKE A RISK AND GIVE COLLEGE
A TRY WITH THE HOPE OF CREATING
A BETTER FUTURE FOR MYSELF.
DESPITE HAVING FINANCIAL AID, I
STILL STRUGGLED TO MAKE ENDS
MEET WHILE IN COLLEGE. IT WASN'T
AN EASY JOURNEY. IT HAS TAKEN ME
SEVEN YEARS TO GET WHERE I AM
TODAY, AT TIMES HAVING TO TAKE A
BREAK FROM COLLEGE JUST TO MAKE
SURE MY BASIC NEEDS WERE MET.
EVERY DOLLAR THAT I SPENT
TOWARDS SCHOOL WAS A DOLLAR THAT
I DIDN'T HAVE FOR FOOD OR
HOUSING. HAVING A CAL KIDS
ACCOUNT COULD HAVE GIVEN ME THE
RESOURCES I NEEDED TO STAY IN
SCHOOL. MY FIRST SEMESTER. THERE
ARE MANY KIDS IN FOSTER CARE,
JUST LIKE ME, WHO DIDN'T THINK
THAT COLLEGE IS POSSIBLE FOR
THEM AND BELIEVE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
EXPANDING THESE COURSES ACCOUNTS
TO ALL YOUTH AND FOSTER CARE IN
THE FIRST THROUGH 12TH GRADE
SENDS THE MESSAGE TO YOUTH THAT
THEY ARE COLLEGE MATERIAL AND
CREATES HOPE THAT RESOURCES ARE
IN PLACE TO HELP THEM SUCCEED.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT IN AB 258.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU, ALL RIGHT, NOW I'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2508 HERE IN ROOM
2100. GOOD MORNING, PAIGE CLARK
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, ANNIE THOMAS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. HI. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS TANISHA
JONES, AND I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH, AND I'M CURRENTLY
ATTENDING SACRAMENTO STATE. AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. CELESTE WICKS WITH
CLEANERS FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT.
ALSO SUPPORTING THIS BILL NORTH
ECO EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAROLINE NGUYEN èC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
CHILDREN NOW AND IN SUPPORT. SAM
NASH ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
2508. SEEING NONE, WE'LL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN WE WHEN WE DO. I KNOW FOR
ME, ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
FOSTER YOUTH IN L.A. COUNTY
RESIDES IN MY DISTRICT. AND
PRE-COVID, ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY
AND MYSELF, ON A REGULAR BASIS
WOULD PULL IN FOSTER YOUTH, BUY
HIM LUNCH AND JUST LISTEN TO
THEIR STORIES. AND IT'S WHEN
IT'S A ROUGH LIFE WITH A LOT OF
TIMES WITH VERY LITTLE HOPE.
THIS ACTUALLY PROVIDES HOPE
WHICH CAN CAN SPARK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, BY THE WAY,
AND THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'RE DOING ON YOUR OWN. IT'S
VERY IMPRESSIVE. BUT WE NEED TO
LIFT UP EVERYBODY. THIS IS A
GREAT PROGRAM. I'M GLAD TO SEE
IT BEING EXPANDED. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK IN
THIS SPACE, IN YOUR ENTIRE
LEGISLATIVE CAREER. I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN A REAL ADVOCATE, AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
ECHO THOSE SENTIMENTS, WEDNESDAY
. WOW. I CAN JUST SEE THE AURA
THAT YOU'RE EMANATING. YOU'RE
JUST AN OLD SOUL. BUT I HAVE TO
SAY, THOSE LIFE EXPERIENCES, AS
HARSH AS THEY MIGHT SEEM, I
THINK HAS BROUGHT FORTH THIS
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADY THAT I THAT
WE SEE BEFORE US. AND I THINK A
LOT OF IT IS BECAUSE OF YOUR
LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT WILL GUIDE
YOU IN LEADERSHIP, MOVING
FORWARD, I'M EXCITED TO SEE YOUR
FUTURE ENDEAVORS AND WHAT YOU
DO. IN THAT CAPACITY. BUT KUDOS
AND CONTINUE ON THAT ON THAT
JOURNEY. AND WHOEVER WAS YOUR
SUPPORT SYSTEM? THANK THEM.
THANK THEM FOR THAT. I THANK
THEM FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE IN HELPING, SUPPORTING YOU,
GETTING YOU THIS FAR ON THAT, I
WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MEMBER
MCCARTHY, FOR A K¾T FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IN EDUCATION AS
WELL. I KNOW WE'VE HAD MANY,
MANY DISCUSSIONS WHEN IT COMES
TO EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR COUNSEL AND YOUR AND YOUR,
YOUR GUIDANCE WITH THAT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK YOU FOR
THOSE REALLY KIND WORDS. YOU
KNOW, THIS IS MY FINAL YEAR
HERE. AND I LOOK ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DID OVER THE
YEARS. AND THIS IS I THINK, ONE
OF OUR HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENTS. AND
THIS IS A WAY TO MAKE IT BETTER.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO, IS
LOOK BACK AT OUR LAWS AND WHERE
DO WE MISS OUT? ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY GETS ME IS
WHAT SENATOR WILK JUST MENTIONED
IS THE LACK OF RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE POPULATION. WE ALL
KNOW THE STATISTICS WEDNESDAY
HERE. YOU KNOW, FRANKLY, A
MIRACLE HERE AND HERE. YOU ARE
SHARING YOUR STORY. AND TOO MANY
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE
YOUR STORY. BUT WHEN YOU GET A
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT WITH
YOUR NAME ON IT, YOU GET A
LETTER TO YOU AND IT'S LIKE, OH,
I HAVE THIS MONEY TO GO TO
COLLEGE. AND THAT'S THE
BRILLIANCE OF THIS WHOLE THING.
IT SETS UP EXPECTATIONS IN
PEOPLE LIKE I HAVE MONEY FOR ME
TO GO TO COLLEGE, AND IT
SHOULDN'T BE JUST TRUST FUND.
KIDS ARE GOING TO GO TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. YOU KNOW, THIS THIS
REALLY HAS A REMARKABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO, TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY AND BUILD UP
EXPECTATIONS FOR SUCCESS. SO
WE'RE GOING TO REALLOCATE THE
EXISTING ALLOCATION, THE BUDGET
FOR THE CAL KIDS PROGRAM, WHICH
HAS BEEN UNDERSUBSCRIBED. SO
THIS WILL MAXIMIZE PARTICIPATION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MAYOR MCCARTHY. WELL, WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN UNTIL, WE'RE READY
TO VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM,
WE ESTABLISH, OKAY, WE SEE
MEMBER WEBER. HERE IN IN OUR,
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM, WHERE
SHE'LL BE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 1919.
AND MEMBER. YES. PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. OKAY. GREAT. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL YOUR THOUGHTFUL WORK AND
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB 1919, WHICH
WILL REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO ADOPT AT LEAST ONE
OF THE EVIDENCE BEST BASED BEST
PRACTICES FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES. FROM
THE LIST OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, THIS BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE PARTICIPATION IN A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAM
IDENTIFIED AS BEST PRACTICE AS
ONE OF THE ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF
CORRECTION THAT SCHOOLS MAY USE
BEFORE THEY CONSIDER SUSPENSION
OF A STUDENT. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE INCIDENCE OF
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS AMONG
CERTAIN POPULATIONS, INCLUDING
BLACK STUDENTS, HAS GAINED
NATIONWIDE ATTENTION IN RECENT
YEARS. DATA SHOWS THAT PUNITIVE
AND OR ZERO TOLERANCE SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE POLICIES THAT RELY
EXCLUSIVELY ON PUNISHMENTS ARE
INEFFECTIVELY AND STAND IN THE
WAY OF STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT. DATA
ALSO SHOWS THAT THESE PUNITIVE
DISCIPLINE POLICIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BLACK
STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY BLACK
MALES, AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. BLACK STUDENTS ARE
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
SUSPENDED THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS, WITHOUT INDICATION
TO SHOW THAT THEY BEHAVE MORE,
MISBEHAVE MORE. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES ENGAGE IN
COLLABORATIVE PROBLEM SOLVING,
AND POWERS CHANGE AND GROWTH AND
FOCUSES ON BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT
ADDRESS DISORDERLY CONDUCT IN A
WAY THAT STRENGTHENS
RELATIONSHIPS. IN 2022, AB 2598
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW, WHICH
REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
STANDARD MODEL TO IMPLEMENT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BEST
PRACTICES FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND MAKE THEM AVAILABLE
ON THEIR WEBSITE. AS A PART OF
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE CAMPUS
CULTURE AND CLIMATE. THIS BILL
WILL BUILD UPON 8528 CREATE A
SUPPORTIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE, AND
WILL ALLOW THE DEDICATED FOCUS
NECESSARY FOR THE SOCIAL,
EMOTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL NEEDS
OF ALL STUDENTS. AB 1919 WILL
ADDRESS REMAINING INEQUITIES
WITHIN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND IMPROVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE, WHICH LEADS TO
INCREASED ATTENDANCE, REDUCED
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION, BULLYING,
CLASSROOM DISRUPTION, TRUANCY,
ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIOR, AND
DISPUTES AMONG STUDENTS,
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE METHODS
ALLOWS FOR GREATER UNDERSTANDING
AND COMMUNITY HEALING IN
ADDRESSING YOUTH BEHAVIOR WITH
ME HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS MARTIN ABDEL KHÎI,
CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER OF
KINGMAKERS OF OAKLAND, AND
TANISHA HERRING, GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS SPECIALIST FROM
CALIFORNIA, HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE, NAACP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DOCTOR WEBER,
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, AND GREETINGS. MY NAME
IS MARTIN ABDULQAWI. I AM THE
CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER FOR
KINGMAKERS OF OAKLAND WITH 30
YEARS IN EDUCATION AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. I HAVE DEDICATED MY
CAREER TO CREATING SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE ALL STUDENTS
CAN THRIVE. I HAVE SERVED AS A
TEACHER, A PRINCIPAL, AND A HIGH
SCHOOL NETWORK SUPERINTENDENT IN
THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
PROMOTE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. OUR
ORGANIZATION, Kò, MAKERS OF
OAKLAND, IS COMMITTED TO
TRANSFORMING THE LIVES OF BLACK
BOYS THROUGH EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT, WE REIMAGINE
SYSTEMS OF EDUCATION, CULTURE
AND WELLNESS WHILE DRIVING
NARRATIVE CHANGE THAT CELEBRATES
BLACK PEOPLE AND CULTURE AND
IMPROVING EDUCATIONAL AND LIFE
OUTCOMES FOR ALL BLACK BOYS. WE
BELIEVE THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IS CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING THESE
GOALS, AS IT DIRECTLY ADDRESSES
THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT LEAD TO
HIGH SUSPENSION RATES AND
EDUCATIONAL DISPARITIES IN
CALIFORNIA, BLACK STUDENTS ARE
SUSPENDED AT RATES THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN THEIR WHITE PEERS.
THIS DISPROPORTIONATE SUSPENSION
RATE LEADS TO SIGNIFICANT
LEARNING LOSS, WITH SUSPENDED
STUDENTS BEING TWICE AS LIKELY
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL FOR BLACK
MALES, THIS REALITY IS EVEN
STARKER, CONTRIBUTING TO A CYCLE
OF DISADVANTAGE AND
DISENGAGEMENT. WHEN I WAS A
PRINCIPAL IN OAKLAND, WE
IMPLEMENTED RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES AND WITNESSED
REMARKABLE TRANSFORMATIONS. ONE
STUDENT WHO HAD FACED MULTIPLE
SUSPENSIONS WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
RESTORATIVE CIRCLE. THIS
INTERVENTION ALLOWED THE STUDENT
TO EXPRESS HIS STRUGGLES, TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY, AND DEVELOP A
PLAN TO ADDRESS THE HARM THAT
WAS CAUSED OVER TIME, THIS
STUDENT IMPROVED ACADEMICALLY
AND EVEN BECAME A PEER MEDIATOR,
HELPING OTHERS NAVIGATE
CONFLICTS. I SAW FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACT OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ON
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AND THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY. KINGMAKERS OF
OAKLAND SUPPORTS AB 1919 BECAUSE
IT ALIGNS WITH OUR CORE VALUES.
KING CENTERED LOVE, AFRICAN
CENTERED, COLLECTIVE WILL AND
PARTNERSHIP. THIS LEGISLATION
PROMISES TO REDUCE SUSPENSIONS
AND PROMOTE RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL TO
EDUCATIONAL AND PERSONAL GROWTH
FOR OUR YOUTH. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 1919 AND HELP US
BUILD A MORE JUST AND INCLUSIVE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR ALL.
THANK YOU SIR. WE USUALLY HAVE A
TIME LIMIT OF FOUR MINUTES. TWO
MINUTES EACH, EACH, WITNESS. SO
YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE JUST
OVER JUST A MINUTE AND 15
SECONDS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANKS. I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED
THAT BEFORE. IT'S OKAY. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
TANISHA HERRING, AND I AM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII NAACP. AND
OUR PRINCIPAL OBJECTIVE IS TO
ENSURE THE POLITICAL,
EDUCATIONAL, SOCIAL, AND
ECONOMIC EQUALITY OF MINORITY
CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELIMINATE RACE PREJUDICE. WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB 1919, AS
THIS BILL DIRECTLY RELATES TO
OUR PREVIOUSLY SPONSORED BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW, AB 1165.
MCCARTY PEOPLE DISCIPLINE FOR AN
INCIDENT OF RACIST, BULLYING,
HARASSMENT OR INTIMIDATION. AB
1165 ENCOURAGED LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO HAVE BOTH THE VICTIM
AND PERPETRATOR ENGAGED IN A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICE
THAT IS FOUND TO SUIT THE NEEDS
OF BOTH THE VICTIM AND THE
PERPETRATOR. AB 1919 TAKES A
STEP FURTHER AND WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT AT LEAST ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S LIST OF BEST
PRACTICES FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE. BEFORE MOVING ON TO
SUSPENSION OR EXPULSION. IN ANY
CASE, BLACK STUDENTS OFTEN FALL
VICTIM TO ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICIES ADOPTED AT SCHOOLS
WHILE HAVING THE INTENTION TO
MAINTAIN STUDENT SAFETY. THESE
POLICIES DISPROPORTIONATELY,
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THEM.
ENFORCING THESE POLICIES.
STUDENTS ARE SUBJECTED TO
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS.
STUDENTS SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED
FOR A DISCRETIONARY VIOLATION
ARE NEARLY THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE IN CONTACT WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. IN EXTREME
CASES, BLACK STUDENTS ARE
ARRESTED AND SENT TO JUVENILE
DETENTION CENTERS BY SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS. ABOUT 15% OF
K THROUGH 12 PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE BLACK, BUT THEY
MAKE UP MORE THAN 30% OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUSPENDED,
EXPELLED OR ARRESTED. ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICIES CRIMINALIZE
CRIMINALIZE BLACK STUDENTS FOR
MINOR INFRACTIONS AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE, PUSHING THEM OUT OF
CLASSROOMS AND INTO THE JUVENILE
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS. WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THIS
BILL, PARTICULARLY THAT THE
MEASURE MANDATES SCHOOLS KEEP
RECORDS OF THE ALTERNATE FORM OF
CORRECTION THAT IS USED,
PARTICULARLY WHEN A KID IS
SUSPENDED AS A LAST RESORT. WE
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR
KYLA WEBER FOR WRITING THIS
CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL
LEGISLATION, AND WE HOPE THAT AB
1919 WILL BE A STARTING POINT
FOR THE MARATHON AHEAD OF US TO
INCREASE THE USE OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IN PLACE OF UTILIZING
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS AS
FIRST CHOICES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THAT WAS A PRETTY
QUICK READING. I WILL NOW
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1919 HERE IN ROOM
2100. SIERRA COOK WITH SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED IN SUPPORT. STELLA
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT KATHLEEN
PFEIFFER, CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
IN SUPPORT SAM NASH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. SUPPORT WONDERFUL.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS,
ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS?
OPPOSITION. OH I GUESS, YEAH, I
FORGOT. SORRY ABOUT THAT. GOOD
POINT. DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 1919? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. SO I JUST HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION. SO THE SCHOOLS HAVE TO
KEEP A RECORD OF WHAT THEY DO.
ARE WE GOING TO BE COLLECTING
THAT DATA? YES. WITH THE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. SO
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT ALL
RIGHT. GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO NO OTHER WE DON'T HAVE
ANY MEMBERS HERE TODAY. SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DOCTOR WEBBER
REALLY APPRECIATE, THOSE WHO
COME WHO CAME OUT AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT, YOU KNOW, I
AM DATA DRIVEN, WHICH IS WHY,
THE ORIGINAL BILL THAT REQUIRED
CTE TO LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES
AND POST THEM ON THE WEBSITE WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST BILLS THAT I
AUTHORED, BECAUSE UNDERSTANDING
THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WORKS,
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS IMPLEMENT THE BEST
PRACTICE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH CHILDREN WHO MAY BE
PERCEIVED TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS FOR WHATEVER
REASON IS GOING ON IN THEIR
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENT. AND INSTEAD
OF PUNISHING THEM OFTENTIMES AT
VERY YOUNG AGES AND TURNING THEM
AWAY FROM SCHOOL AND EDUCATION,
THIS IS A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN
BRING THEM IN, SHOW THEM THAT
THEY MEAN ENOUGH TO THE
COMMUNITY AND TO THE SCHOOL SO
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO FOCUS
ON WHAT'S IMPORTANT, WHICH IS
GETTING THEIR EDUCATION COMING
BACK AND GIVING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY TO GIVE THEM THAT HAD
GIVEN THEM SO MUCH. AND SO THIS
IS EXTREMELY CRITICAL. I AM A
MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG BLACK BOYS
AND AM VERY ASHAMED TO SAY THAT
MY OLDEST DEALT WITH SOME
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES
DISPROPORTIONATELY, STARTING AT
THE AGE OF THREE, AND THIS WAS
WHEN HIS MOTHER, HIS
GRANDMOTHER, WAS A STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HIS MOTHER
WAS A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN. ALL
OF US HAD GRADUATE DEGREES, SO
IT IS REAL. IT HAPPENS. AND THIS
IS ONE WAY TO STOP IT. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE
ON AB 1919. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
DOCTOR RIVER. AND THANK YOU TO
OUR WITNESSES FOR COMING HERE
TODAY. AND TESTIFYING. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. WE'LL NOW
MOVE FORWARD WITH Ó. OKAY.
MEMBER HOOVER, FIRST, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11. MADAM CHAIR, I I'M
GOING TO LET, MIGUEL SKIP ME.
OH, OKAY. THANK YOU. I PROMISED
THAT I WOULD BE QUICK. OKAY, SO
WE HAVE MEMBER SANTIAGO
PRESENTING FILE ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2093. WELCOME. THANK YOU. AND
I JUST WANT TO KEEP MY
COMMITMENT TO BEING QUICKENED
FOR NO OTHER REASON, OTHERWISE,
I'D LOVE TO PRESENT FOR THIS FOR
AN HOUR, BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON SINCE 2017
WHERE WE'VE MADE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FREE. FOR ALL STUDENTS
AVAILABLE IF THEY GO FULL TIME.
TODAY WE PRESENT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EDUCATION FREE, EVEN
FOR A BA. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. NOW IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I WILL MOVE
OVER TO MY TO MY TWO WITNESSES.
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK MR. WILK,
WHO WENT FIRST BACK IN 2013.
SORRY 2017. WE INTRODUCED IT. HE
REACHED ACROSS THE AISLE, HAVING
HAD COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACKGROUND, IN HIS OWN IN HIS
OWN HISTORY THAT HE UNDERSTOOD
AND WE UNDERSTOOD HOW IMPORTANT
IT WAS TO GIVE FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. SOME FOLKS MIGHT SAY,
WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S A HANDOUT,
BUT REALLY, WHAT IT IS, IS FOR
FULL TIME STUDENTS AND THE
SUCCESS RATE FOR STUDENTS, JUMPS
UP EXPONENTIALLY WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU COMMIT TO GOING TO FULL
TIME. SO NOT ONLY DOES THIS MAKE
SENSE FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE
IN NEED, BUT IT ALSO MAKES SENSE
FOR THE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION
WHICH NOW INCREASES ITS FULL
TIME. IT'S SORRY. IT'S, IT'S
ENROLLMENT HOURS, BUT IT ALSO
MAKES SENSE FOR SOCIETY IN
GENERAL WHEN YOU HAVE STUDENTS
NOW GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR FREE WHO HAVE COMMITTED TO
GO FULL TIME, WHICH THEIR
SUCCESS RATE IS MUCH HIGHER. SO
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS, FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAKES SENSE.
TODAY WE WANT TO INTRODUCE THAT
TO FOR BAS AS WELL. AND WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM VICE
VICE CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MARIA LUISA VELOZ AND I'M
SHARING TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ, THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT, THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IS THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB 2093, AB 2093, AN EXPANSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO PURSUE
THEIR BACCALAUREATE DEGREE AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO COMPLETE
THAT DEGREE, TUITION FREE AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
THEIR CHOICE, RELIEVING THEM OF
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDEN BY
CHOOSING TO PURSUE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AT LACCD, STUDENTS CAN
SAVE SIGNIFICANTLY ON TUITION
COSTS. THE APPROXIMATE COST OF A
BA DEGREE AT LACCD IS $10,560,
AS COMPARED TO THE ESTIMATED 30
$30,000 PRICE TAG FOR A CSU FOUR
YEAR DEGREE. FURTHERMORE, AS YOU
AS YOU KNOW, CSU IS PROJECTED TO
INCREASE TUITION BY 30% OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS, ACCORDING TO A
RECENT UCLA STUDY, STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACHELOR'S PROGRAMS HAD AN
AVERAGE INCOME OF ROUGHLY
$40,000. THESE STUDENTS ARE
LIKELY TO BE OLDER, A THIRD OF
THEM BETWEEN THE AGES OF 30 AND
39 YEARS OLD. THEY HAVE FAMILIES
AND DEPENDENTS. IMMEDIATELY UPON
COMPLETING THEIR BA DEGREE, THEY
EARNED AN AVERAGE OF $65,000.
UPON COMPLETION. COMPLETION OF
THEIR DEGREE AB 29 2093 IS A
LEGISLATIVE VICTORY FOR EQUITY
AND HIGHER EDUCATION THAT WILL
UPLIFT THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES BY
CREATING PATHWAYS TO HIGHER
PAYING JOBS. IT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THE
ECONOMIC LANDSCAPE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND FOR THAT REASON,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CELIA ESPOSITO
NÓI AND I AM THE SUPERINTENDENT
PRESIDENT AT SOLANO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. AS MANY
PROFESSIONS REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE, COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAMS
ARE ESSENTIAL FOR STUDENTS
WISHING TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE AND
RELEVANT PROGRAMS THAT MEET
WORKFORCE NEEDS. APPROXIMATELY
1600 STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES STATEWIDE. STUDENTS ARE
OPTING TO ENROLL AND COMPLETE
THEIR BA DEGREES AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THEY CAN REMAIN CLOSE TO
HOME, BUT BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS
MAKE THEM JOB READY. THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE HIGH SUCCESS
RATES. FOR EXAMPLE, AT SOLANO
COLLEGE, 100% OF OUR
BIOMANUFACTURING STUDENTS
GRADUATE AND 100% OF THOSE
GRADUATES SECURE EMPLOYMENT AND
OR ARE ACCEPTED INTO GRADUATE
PROGRAMS. THE AVERAGE STARTING
SALARY FOR THESE GRADUATES IS
$80,000 A YEAR. THESE BACHELOR
DEGREES ARE AFFORDABLE AND EQUIP
OUR COMMUNITY WITH AN EDUCATED
WORKFORCE TO MEET LOCAL DEMANDS.
95% OF THE STUDENTS WHO COMPLETE
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA. IF AB 2093 IS
PASSED, IT WOULD ALLOW US TO SEE
OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM FUNDS TO MAKE
THE BACCALAUREATE DEGREES FREE
FOR ALL FOUR YEARS, PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS, IN TURN, WOULD PROVIDE OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH AN EDUCATED
WORKFORCE THAT IS NOT SADDLED
WITH STUDENT DEBT. JUST LIKE AB
19 MADE THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FREE AND SB
850 AND AB 927 EXPANDED ACCESS
TO BACCALAUREATE DEGREES. THIS
IS ANOTHER LANDMARK BILL THAT
WILL IMPROVE ACCESS AND
COMPLETION RATES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS, I
REQUEST THAT YOU VOTE YES ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL NOW
MOVE FORWARD WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2093. WELCOME
THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR MEMBERS,
MARK MCDONALD. I HAVE A LIST
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY, CONTRA COSTA, FOOTHILL
DEANZA, PALO VERDE, PERALTA, SAN
BERNARDINO, SAN DIEGO, AND
SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS, AS WELL AS THE LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE FACULTY GUILD
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
ASSOCIATION. AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
IT'S BEEN GREAT WORKING WITH YOU
OVER THESE YEARS ON THIS, THIS,
GOAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI.
GOOD MORNING, CAROL GONZALEZ. ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MOORLACH, ON BEHALF OF
CFT, IN ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT
FROM MY MEMBERS. SO THANK YOU,
CELESTE WICKS, FOR CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT. ALSO IN
SUPPORT NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
JUSTICE AND ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PEEPS. THANK YOU, CÁC MANZINI,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT BELLA KERN ON BEHALF OF
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE, IN SUPPORT
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2093. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. I KNOW WE HAVE TO
BE OUT OF THIS ROOM FOR ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING, SO SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL YOUR WORK IN THIS SPACE,
IT'S GOING TO BE LOST FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE AND FOR CALIFORNIANS
THAT THAT YOU'RE LEAVING US. I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO GO OFF AND
DO BIGGER AND BETTER THINGS, BUT
IT'S REALLY BEEN A PLEASURE
SERVING WITH YOU. MEMBER
SANTANA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE? THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
OH, SORRY. SORRY. BEFORE WE
CLOSE, JUST MADE AWARE, DO YOU
ACCEPT THE AMEND? YES, I DO, AND
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT NOT STATING
THAT AT THE BEGINNING. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY, WONDERFUL.
SO THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED, ONCE AGAIN,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THAT
VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL HAVE TO
WAIT FOR A QUORUM BEFORE WE'RE
ABLE TO VOTE ON THIS. THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE. FORWARD
WITH MEMBER HOOVER. WE'RE GOING
TO BE PRESENTING OR HE'S GOING
TO BE PRESENTING FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11, AB 3216. SUPPORT YOUR
BILL THAT I GOT TO GO VOTE. NO
WORRIES. THANK YOU. SENATOR, IF
IT GETS AMENDED, I'D LIKE TO BE
A COAUTHOR. OKAY. MY STAFF SAID
IT COULDN'T BE DONE. SO KUDOS TO
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR. YOU GOT
IT. YOU WILL HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS
A COAUTHOR. YEAH. THAT WAS,
SENATOR, FOR THOSE THAT COULD
NOT HEAR, SENATOR WILK HAS
OFFERED OR REQUESTED TO BE ADDED
AS A COAUTHOR. I HAVEN'T EVEN
SAID ANYTHING YET, SO WELCOME,
MEMBER HOOVER. AND WHEN YOU'RE
READY, PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT, THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL, ASSEMBLY BILL 3216, I'M
HERE TODAY, OBVIOUSLY AS A
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY, BUT ALSO
AS A PARENT, HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
OF A MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENT, AND
OF AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENT.
SO A CHILDREN WHO SPAN THE AGE
RANGE AND WILL BE AFFECTED BY
THE IMPACTS OF AB 3216, OUR KIDS
ARE IN CRISIS, RATES OF
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY IN THE
UNITED STATES HAVE RISEN BY MORE
THAN 50% FROM 2010 TO 2019. THE
SUICIDE RATE HAS RISEN 48% FOR
ADOLESCENTS AGED 10 TO 19 AND
FOR GIRLS AGED 10 TO 14, THE
SUICIDE RATE HAS GONE UP 131%
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
RATES OF CYBERBULLYING ARE ALSO
AT AN ALL TIME HIGH. AND WHEN I
WAS LOOKING AT INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION, I HAD TO ASK MYSELF
, AND AFTER READING A NUMBER OF
STUDIES ON THIS AS WELL, WHAT IS
THE CORRELATION HERE? WHAT HAS
HAPPENED DURING THAT PERIOD OF
TIME THAT HAS LED TO THIS, YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS
THAT HAS CHANGED IS THAT
SMARTPHONES HAVE BECOME MUCH
MORE PREVALENT IN THE HANDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. STARTING IN THE
EARLY 20 TENS, GRADES WE KNOW
SUFFER WHEN LEARNING IS
DISRUPTED AS A RESULT OF
SMARTPHONE DISTRACTIONS IN THE
CLASSROOM. UP TO 15% OF
TEENAGERS ENGAGE REPORTEDLY
ENGAGE IN PROBLEMATIC SOCIAL
MEDIA USE, WHICH INCLUDES
SYMPTOMS SUCH AS PREOCCUPATION,
WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS, NEGLECT OF
OTHER AREAS OF LIFE, AND LYING
TO PARENTS AND FRIENDS ABOUT
TIME SPENT ON SOCIAL MEDIA. IN
THE LATEST GALLUP DATA THAT WE
HAVE, AMERICAN TEENAGERS
REPORTED SPENDING AROUND FIVE
HOURS PER DAY ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ALONE, SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED IN OUR
HISTORY. PRIOR TO THE EARLY 20
TENS, WE HAVE SEEN A 70%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS, EXPRESSING THAT
LIFE OFTEN FEELS MEANINGLESS.
NOW, MORE THAN 1 IN 5 SENIORS
EXPRESS THIS. POOR MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND SMARTPHONE USE ARE
ALSO MOST STRONGLY CORRELATED IN
KIDS UNDER THE AGE OF 14. AND SO
A LOT OF THE THESE STATISTICS
ARE WHY IS WHAT LED ME TO
INTRODUCE AB 3216, WHICH IS A
VERY SIMPLE BILL. IT WILL
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO TAKE
ACTION TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS,
SIMPLY BY REQUIRING THEM TO PASS
A POLICY LIMITING SMARTPHONE USE
IN THE CLASSROOM, DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY DONE THIS ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE SEEN INCREDIBLE
RESULTS. AND MOMENTUM IS GROWING
FOR THIS MOVEMENT ACROSS THE
WORLD. AS NOTED IN THE BILL, IN
SEPTEMBER 2018, FRANCE ADOPTED A
NATIONWIDE SMARTPHONE BAN IN ALL
PRIMARY AND MIDDLE SCHOOLS IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE PUPIL
ACHIEVEMENT AND HEALTHY SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT. LONDON HAS ENGLAND
HAS DONE SOMETHING SIMILAR, AND
THE LONDON SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS
AND POLITICAL SCIENCE PUBLISHED
IN 2015 A STUDY THAT FOUND TEST
SCORES IMPROVED SIGNIFICANTLY AT
SCHOOLS THAT BANNED MOBILE PHONE
USE, AND THAT THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GAINS IN PUPIL
PERFORMANCE WERE MADE BY THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDERACHIEVING PUPILS. ANOTHER
MAJOR GOAL THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN 2015, SPAIN
ENACTED A RESTRICTION ON MOBILE
PHONES IN SCHOOL SETTINGS
SHOWING AN INCREASE OF STUDENTS
TEST SCORES, AS WELL AS A
DOCUMENTED DECREASE IN INCIDENTS
OF BULLYING, I THINK I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'VE ALREADY
HAD ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE OUR
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE, AL MURATSUCHI, AS A
JOINT AUTHOR AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JOSH LOWENTHAL IS A
JOINT AUTHOR. ALSO WAS VERY
GRATEFUL TO SEE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
COME OUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
CONCEPT LAST WEEK, AND THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA, LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
JUST PASSED A POLICY ON THIS AS
WELL. I WANT TO KEEP UP THIS
MOMENTUM, SO WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BEFORE I CLOSE, TURN IT OVER TO
MY WITNESSES. I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT A COUPLE POINTS THAT I
THINK THE OPPOSITION WILL LIKELY
RAISE, WE CRAFTED THIS BILL VERY
CAREFULLY TO PROVIDE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CRAFT THE POLICIES THAT WORK
BEST FOR THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
NOTHING IN MY BILL PRESCRIBES
WHAT HAS TO BE DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT
ACTION BE TAKEN AND SO I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT. THE
BILL ALSO PROVIDES EXCEPTIONS
DURING EMERGENCIES WHEN
PERMISSION IS GIVEN BY A TEACHER
OR ADMINISTRATOR. WHEN A DOCTOR
DEEMS THE SMARTPHONE USE
NECESSARY, OR WHEN THE
SMARTPHONE IS REQUIRED IN AN
IEP. VERY EXCITED TO HAVE WITH
ME TODAY TWO WONDERFUL PEOPLE
FROM MY DISTRICT. GOING TO START
WITH, TARIQ, TARIQ MCFALL, WHO
IS THE PRINCIPAL OF SUTTER
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN FOLSOM AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY DAVID REED, WHO IS
THE A BOARD MEMBER AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE FOLSOM UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU. AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
TARIQ MCFALL. I'M GOING INTO MY
FOURTH YEAR AS PROUD PRINCIPAL
AT SUTTER MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
FOLSOM, CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I WANTED TO SPEAK TO
YOU BRIEFLY ABOUT MY EXPERIENCES
WITH SMARTPHONES ON CAMPUS.
PRIOR TO THE 2324 SCHOOL YEAR.
WE DID, STUDENTS IN SIXTH,
SEVENTH, AND EIGHTH GRADE WERE
ALLOWED TO HAVE THEIR THEIR CELL
PHONES DURING LUNCH TIME. AND
WHAT I HAVE FOUND IN MY IN MY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE, 12 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL, I
FOUND NØ NØ SITUATIONS,
SITUATIONS WHERE STUDENTS SHOULD
HAVE THEIR CELL PHONES OUT ON
CAMPUS. SO IT MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO MONITOR. AND SO
DURING THE 2023 2024 SCHOOL
YEAR, OUR BOARD, AND, VOTED ON A
POLICY WHICH ALLOWED WHICH KEPT
STUDENTS FROM HAVING THEIR
PHONES DURING LUNCH. AND WHAT WE
FOUND ON OUR CAMPUS WERE LESS
AND LESS INCIDENTS WHERE
STUDENTS WERE AIR DROPPING,
INAPPROPRIATE MATERIALS ON THEIR
CELL PHONES. THERE WERE NO THERE
WERE NO INCIDENTS OF VANDALISM
IN OUR RESTROOMS. WE HAD A
REDUCTION OF FIGHTS ON CAMPUS.
SO WHAT WE ALSO SAW FOR THE
POSITIVE ASPECT WERE MORE
STUDENTS GOING TO THE LIBRARY,
MORE STUDENTS JOINING CLUBS AT
LUNCH, MORE STUDENTS ACTUALLY
HAVING FACE TO FACE
CONVERSATIONS, WHICH WAS
REMARKABLE. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
A REALLY A POWERFUL EMAIL I
RECEIVED FROM A PARENT WHO ALSO
SAID SHE EMAILED ME AND SAID HOW
HAPPY SHE WAS ABOUT THIS POLICY
BECAUSE HER CHILD, THEIR FAMILY,
HAD CHOSEN NOT TO HAVE CELL
PHONES OR BUY THEIR CHILD A CELL
PHONE, AND DURING LUNCH, HIS
SIXTH GRADE YEAR, HIS, HIS TWO
FRIENDS HAD CELL PHONES, BUT HE
DIDN'T. AND HE FOUND IT VERY
HARD TO KIND OF INTERACT WITH
THEM DURING THAT TIME. AND THIS
PAST SCHOOL YEAR, HE'S BEEN ABLE
TO, WITH THE CELL PHONES PUT
AWAY. THEY'VE BEEN THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE ACTUAL
CONVERSATIONS. AND, AND AGAIN,
WHAT I'VE, WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
JUST A TREMENDOUS, POSITIVE
INFLUENCE BY NOT HAVING CELL
PHONES OUT. AND SO BY FOR THAT,
I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT I,
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT, AB THREE
3216 AND MOVING FORWARD, I THINK
IT WILL BE A GREAT WAY FOR ALL
SCHOOLS TO MOVE FORWARD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS DAVID READ
AND I AM A TRUSTEE WITH THE
FOLSOM CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S BOARD OF EDUCATION.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 3216
AND TO SHARE FC USD'S EXPERIENCE
WITH ADOPTING A CELL PHONE
POLICY. FCSD WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE TO ADOPT A CELL PHONE
POLICY IN 2020, BEFORE ADOPTING
THE POLICY, WE SOUGHT THE INPUT
FROM PARENTS, TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS. BASED ON THIS INPUT,
WE DECIDED TO ADOPT A GRADUATED
POLICY WHERE WE BANNED CELL
PHONES IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. WE
ALLOWED THE USE OF CELL PHONES
AT LUNCH TIME AT MIDDLE SCHOOLS,
AND WE ALLOWED THE USE OF CELL
PHONES AT LUNCH TIME AND DURING
PASSING PERIODS AT HIGH SCHOOL.
THE POLICY WAS A COMPLETE
SUCCESS. AT THE ELEMENTARY
LEVEL, OUR EXPERIENCE AT THE
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL LEVELS
WAS MORE CHALLENGING. MANY
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
CONTINUED TO USE CELL PHONES
DURING CLASS INSTRUCTION DESPITE
THE NEW POLICY, NOT TO MENTION
USING THEIR PHONES FOR OTHER
PURPOSES IN CONTRADICTION TO
BOARD POLICY BASED ON
FRUSTRATIONS EXPRESSED BY MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHERS, THE FCSD BOARD
AMENDED OUR POLICY IN 2023 TO
EXTEND THE CELL PHONE BAN TO
MIDDLE SCHOOLS. THIS BAN TOOK
EFFECT WITH THE 2324 SCHOOL
YEAR. WE HAD AN IMMEDIATE
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE IN OUR
MIDDLE SCHOOLS ONCE THE PLAN,
ONCE THE BAN TOOK EFFECT, ONE
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER
HEARTBREAKINGLY COMMENTED. SHE
FORGOT WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO HAVE
STUDENTS PAY ATTENTION TO HER.
AS OTHER DISTRICTS LEARNED ABOUT
OUR POLICY, WE STARTED TO
RECEIVE REQUESTS TO SHARE OUR
POLICY WITH THEM. AS A RESULT OF
OUR MIDDLE SCHOOL EXPERIENCE,
THE FCSD BOARD WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE PROS AND CONS OF
EXTENDING OUR CELL PHONE BAN TO
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AT A SEPTEMBER
BOARD MEETING. THIS WAS FC USD'S
EXPERIENCE. I RECOGNIZED THAT
EVERY DISTRICT HAS THEIR OWN
ISSUES AND WHAT WORKS FOR ONE
DISTRICT MIGHT NOT WORK FOR
ANOTHER DISTRICT. THAT IS WHY I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT ELEMENT IN AB 3216 IS
THAT IT ONLY REQUIRES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADOPT A POLICY. IT
DOES NOT TELL THEM WHAT THE
POLICY MUST SAY, LEAVING THAT TO
LOCAL CONTROL. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
3216 HEARING ROOM 2100. ON
ARCHIMEDES, ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU. DO
WE SEE WE HAVE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? WE'LL NOW
CONTINUE WITH ANY, WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 3216. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO ME,
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. AND IT'S INTERESTING. WE
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AND A LOT OF, AS YOU
SAID, MOMENTUM WITH REGARDS TO,
THE CELL PHONES AND THE IMPACT
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA HAS ON THE
BRAIN, INTERESTING TO NOTE. I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
BACK IN THE DAY. SO MY OLDEST
CHILD WAS 24, 22, AND MY
YOUNGEST IS 18, JUST GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL. BUT WHEN I WAS
IN, I DID THE IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AT THAT TIME WHEN THEY
WERE LITTLE, THEY HAD A
PRESCHOOL PARENTING PROGRAM
WHERE THE STUDENT WAS ACTUALLY
THE PARENT, AND THERE WAS A
PRESCHOOL PARENT, A PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AND IN THAT, EVERY WEEK
WE HAD CLASSES WHERE THE PARENTS
WOULD SPLIT UP AND WE WOULD
TAKE, CLASSES ON CHILD
DEVELOPMENT, BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
OR CHILD DEVELOPMENT. BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT, POSITIVE PARENTING,
SCHOOL PARENTING, POSITIVE
PARENTING SKILLS, AS WELL AS
OTHER SUBJECT MATTERS THAT WERE
IMPORTANT TO PARENTS IN HELPING
THEM BECOME BETTER PARENTS AND
RAISING THEIR CHILDREN. BUT IN
ONE OF THOSE CLASSES THAT WE HAD
BACK THEN, AND THIS WAS WHAT
PROBABLY 19 YEARS AGO, 18, 19
YEARS AGO, THEY HAD A CLASS,
SEGMENT ON TECHNOLOGY AND THE
IMPACT THAT IT HAD ON OUR BRAIN.
AND THEY SHOWED US SLIDES AND
PICTURES OF WHAT, YOU KNOW, EVEN
TWO HOURS OF TECHNOLOGY AND HOW
THAT REWIRED AND THE BRAIN
LOOKED DIFFERENTLY ON IN A
CHILD'S BRAIN. SO FROM A VERY
YOUNG AGE, I MEAN, WE'VE HAD
THIS KNOWLEDGE FOR, FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS IN WHICH WE'VE BEEN
KNOWN THAT TECHNOLOGY REALLY
DOES IMPACT REWIRES THE BRAIN IN
OUR IN OUR CHILDREN. HOW THAT
IMPACTS THEIR PERSONALITY,
THEIR, THEIR, BEHAVIOR, AND SO
I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION, WHICH IS WHY MY
CHILDREN DO NOT HAVE, CELL
PHONES WHEN THEY WERE LITTLE AND
I WAS INCREDIBLY UPSET WHEN MY
HUSBAND DECIDED TO GIVE THEM A
CELL PHONE THERE IN JUNIOR HIGH,
I WAS LIKE, WHAT, WITHOUT
CONSULTING THEIR MOTHER? SO
NEEDLESS TO SAY, WE HAD A VERY,
VERY HEAVY DISCUSSION, AT THAT
TIME. BUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR THIS
BILL, THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
FORWARD. AND I'M BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOES CARRY ON THAT
MOMENTUM AND THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'RE HAVING, THAT WE
SHOULD BE HAVING, AT THIS TIME.
SO WITH THAT, YOU KNOW, I'LL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
THE OPPORTUNITY COMES FORWARD.
SO APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE MEMBER CALDERON, HERE,
WELCOME. AND SHE WILL BE
PRESENTING FINAL ITEM, NUMBER 24
AB 3240. GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I THINK IT'S STILL
MORNING, ISN'T IT? YES. GOOD
MORNING. MEMBER. MADAM CHAIR.
YES SO, MORNING, I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3240,
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE
DISPLACEMENT OF GIFT AID AWARDS
UPON THE RECEIPT OF PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT
AWARDS. EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHED
BY THE CALIFORNIA BAN ON
SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT ACT
PROHIBITS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FROM REDUCING STUDENTS
INSTITUTION BASED GIFT AID OFFER
BELOW THEIR FINANCIAL NEED.
HOWEVER, THE SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT ACT ONLY APPLIES TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FEDERAL PELL GRANT OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT,
PROHIBITING THE PRACTICE OF
SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT IS
ESSENTIAL TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE. ADDING CAL GRANT
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA BAN ON SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT ACT WOULD IMPACT
NEARLY 92,000 STUDENTS. AB 3240
ENSURES OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS RECEIVE GREATER ACCESS,
EQUITY AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO ACHIEVE THEIR COLLEGE DREAMS.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN SUPPORTED
UNANIMOUSLY THUS FAR AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS SUPRIYA PATEL, A
STUDENT AND POLICY MANAGER AT
WHAT WE ALL DESERVE. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED, MY
NAME IS SUPRIYA PATEL AND I AM A
POLICY MANAGER AT WHAT WE ALL
DESERVE A YOUTH LED ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION. I'M ALSO
AN INCOMING COLLEGE FRESHMAN AND
SO I AM VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
ISSUE OF PAYING FOR COLLEGE,
ESPECIALLY WITH EXORBITANTLY
HIGH COLLEGE TUITIONS. CURRENTLY
STUDENTS WITH EXISTING FINANCIAL
NEED ARE UNABLE TO FULLY UTILIZE
OUTSIDE SCHOLARSHIPS WHEN HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS REDUCE
THEIR FINANCIAL AID, FINANCIAL
AID IS FREQUENTLY REDUCED BY THE
AMOUNT OF THE PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIP KNOWN AS SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT, WHICH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALSO MENTIONED, AND THIS
RESULTS IN ESSENTIALLY NO NET
BENEFIT FOR STUDENTS. AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA BAN ON SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT ACT CURRENTLY
PREVENTS INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT BENEFIT FROM
STATE FUNDING, OR THAT ENROLL
STUDENTS RECEIVING STATE FUNDED
FINANCIAL AID FROM REDUCING
STUDENTS INSTITUTIONAL AID
OFFERS BELOW THEIR FINANCIAL
NEED, AND AB 3240 WOULD INCREASE
EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION BY
EXTENDING THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BAN ON SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANTS. PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
LOWERING THE COST OF COLLEGE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE MOST NEED,
SUCH SCHOLARSHIPS HELP STUDENTS
PAY FOR CLASSROOM MATERIALS,
TRANSPORTATION, AND ROOM, AND
BOARD, A LOT OF WHICH ARE NOT
COVERED IN STATE FUNDED
SCHOLARSHIPS. AB 3240 LEVELS.
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS, HELPING THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION ASPIRATIONS. AND AS AN
EXCITED INCOMING COLLEGE
FRESHMAN AND RECENT COLLEGE
GRADUATE, I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB 3240 AND THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TIME. TODAY, WE'LL NOW
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3240. SORRY, I
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLOSER TO THE
MIC. VALERIE JOHNSON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JESSE HERNANDEZ REYES WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, JUAN
NUNEZ. ON BEHALF OF THE
TELEVISION ACADEMY FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
3240. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO ME. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. AND WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESSES FOR COMING
IN, IN, IN TESTIFYING. MADAM,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE THAT.
FOR THOSE THAT JUST TUNED IN, WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED, AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY MEMBERS ABOUT MYSELF. SO
WE'RE HOLDING ON TO THE BILLS
UNTIL EVERYBODY, COMES BACK.
RIGHT. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH MEMBER FRIEDMAN,
WE'RE GOING TO SHE'LL BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER 14, AB
2507. AND WELCOME, MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OR MADAM
CHAIR. AS WE ALL KNOW, FINANCIAL
BARRIERS POSE SIGNIFICANT
OBSTACLES FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS STRIVING TO COMPLETE
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION. HIGH
TUITION FEES, ALONG WITH
EXPENSES RELATED TO HOUSING,
TRANSPORTATION, TEXTBOOKS, ETC.
OFTEN FORCE OUR STUDENTS TO
JUGGLE MULTIPLE JOBS TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. THE ISSUE IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE GRAPPLING
WITH INCREASED LEVELS OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT. MOREOVER, THE LONG
TERM REPERCUSSIONS OF REPAYING
STUDENT LOAN DEBT OVER SEVERAL
DECADES CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED.
WITH THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE OF
STUDENT LOAN INTEREST RATES IN
CALIFORNIA SOARING AS HIGH AS 9,
AB 2507 WOULD ESTABLISH A PILOT
INTEREST FREE AND NØ FREE
STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, LOS
ANGELES, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, NORTHRIDGE, AND
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
MEET THE SKYROCKETING DEMANDS
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW INCOME,
HOMELESS, AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS, OR FOOD INSECURE
TO HAVE THEIR FINANCIAL NEEDS
MET WHILE IN PURSUIT OF A HIGHER
EDUCATION. IMPLEMENTING AN
INTEREST FREE, NO FEE STUDENT
LOAN PROGRAM WOULD AFFORD
GRADUATES THE CHANCE TO REPAY
THEIR LOANS WITHIN A REASONABLE
TIME FRAME. WHILE SAVING TO
START A BUSINESS, BUY A HOME,
PAY THEIR RENT ALL THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE NEED TO DO TO
SUCCEED. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON IS
CLIFF BURG WITH THE JEWISH FREE
LOAN ASSOCIATION AND THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL, I
BELIEVE, IS ALSO A JEWISH CAUCUS
TO KUMBALAM PRIORITY BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIRMAN, CLIFF BURG AND BEHALF
OF THE JEWISH FREE LOAN
ASSOCIATION, HERE IS SPONSOR OF
AB 2507. URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
PILOT ZERO INTEREST, ZERO FEE
LOAN PROGRAM. STUDENTS AS YOU
KNOW, ARE HAVING AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TIME MEETING THE
SKYROCKETING DEMAND. FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT, PARTICULARLY
LOW INCOME HOMELESS AND AT RISK
STUDENTS WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL. THE JEWISH
FREE LOAN ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
PROVIDING ZERO INTEREST NÓ FREE
LOANS FOR OVER 120 YEARS AND
UNDERSTANDS FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
THESE LOANS HAVE ON STUDENTS
FACING DIRE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. INTEREST FREE, NO
FEE NO FEE LOANS ARE A LIFELINE
TO THOSE IN NEED AND REPEATEDLY
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO
TURN. CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE
FACING MORE AND MORE OBSTACLES
AS THEY NAVIGATE GETTING INTO
AND GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE.
FINANCIAL BARRIERS HINDER LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FROM COMPLETING
COLLEGE DUE TO HIGH TUITION,
HOUSING, TRANSPORTATION, AND
TEXTBOOK COSTS, OFTEN LEADING TO
MULTIPLE JOBS AND ACCUMULATING
STUDENT DEBT. I THINK THIS
PROGRAM IS PARTICULARLY UNIQUE
AT THIS TIME BECAUSE NOT ONLY IS
IT NO INTEREST, NO FEE, BUT THE
LOANS ARE ABLE TO BE USED FOR
SUPPORT, NOT JUST FOR TUITION
AND BOOKS, BUT FOR
TRANSPORTATION, HOUSING AND
OTHER LIFE NECESSITIES THAT
WITHOUT FINANCIAL SUPPORT,
STUDENTS ARE AT RISK OF DROPPING
OUT OF THE SYSTEM. JEWISH FREE
LOAN HAS BEEN PROVIDING AS MANY
LOANS AS THEY CAN. THE PROGRAM
IS OVERSUBSCRIBED. JEWISH FREE
LOAN HAS OVER $18 MILLION IN
LOANS OUTSTANDING. STARTED
PROVIDING LOANS 120 YEARS AGO
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES FOR
EVERYTHING FROM BIRTH TO DEATH.
THEY CONTINUE TO MEET THOSE
DEMANDS, BUT THERE IS AN
OVERWHELMING DEMAND FROM LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHO NEED HELP
STAYING IN SCHOOL. AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO DEMONSTRATE IN THIS
PILOT PROJECT THE IMPORTANCE OF
NOT PILING ON ADDITIONAL
INTEREST AND FEES ON STUDENTS
WHO NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT. SO
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND ASK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, FOR THE FIRST TIME,
TO EXPLORE THE ADVANTAGE OF
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH NO
INTEREST, NO FEE LOANS. URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SIR. WE'LL NOW CONTINUE
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2507. SEEING NONE WILL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2507. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK. I
WILL JUST ADD IN BEHALF OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JPAC JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
ANOTHER CLIENT IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND IS A PRIORITY BILL
FOR THIS YEAR. THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU. SO FOR THE
SAKE OF DISCUSSION, THE LOAN
PROGRAM WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE, BY THESE COLLEGES, CORRECT?
CORRECT. I BELIEVE SO, AND
BACKED BY, THE FUNDING WOULD BE
COMING FROM WE ARE LOOKING FOR
AN ALLOCATION. OKAY. BY THE
STATE. YEAH. OKAY. THIS IS MONEY
THAT WILL COME BACK TO THE
STATE. IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
GRANT PROGRAM. THESE ARE LOANS
ARE LOANS. YEAH. THE NOTION IS
IT'S A REVOLVING FUND. SO ONE OF
THE ADVANTAGES OF THE PROGRAM
AND WHAT WE WANT TO DEMONSTRATE
IS JEWISH FREE LOAN HAS LIKE A
99.9% REPAYMENT RATE, AND THERE
ARE NO OF COURSE, PENALTY FEES
FOR ANY KIND OF DEFAULT. SO THE
PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED ITS
EFFECTIVENESS IN GETTING THE
MONEY BACK. SO WHATEVER INITIAL
FUNDING WE'RE ABLE TO WORK OUT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROGRAM WOULD GO INTO THAT
REVOLVING FUND AND CONTINUE TO
HELP STUDENTS. WONDERFUL. WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, SIR, FOR COMING HERE
TODAY, MURPHY, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? JUST WOULD REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE WHEN PEOPLE COME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HAVE A GREAT DAY.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
RECESS UNTIL, FURTHER. MEMBERS,
ARRIVE. SO AUTHORS AND MEMBERS,
COME BACK TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. SO THANK YOU. AND,
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MEETING IN 30S. IN THE MEANTIME,
WE WILL ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
TO WORK HIS WAY UP TO THE PODIUM
FOR FINAL ITEM. 18. THANK YOU.
MIGHT CHANCE TO TURN THE. AS YOU
FORMALLY RECESSED BEFORE. WE ARE
OFFICIALLY RECONVENED HERE IN
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
MEETING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
COLLEAGUES. WHICH BILL MIGHT BE
BEST, APPROPRIATE? WAS IT, AB
2883? PERFECT. BECAUSE I HAVE
TWO BEFORE YOU AS WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2883, TO
RECOGNIZE THE CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF LUNAR NEW YEAR,
TO WHICH I KNOW, SENATOR, YOU
ALSO HAVE A LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR ASIAN
ISLANDER COMMUNITY AS AN
OFFICIAL HOLIDAY AT BOTH THE CSU
AND UC CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. ANY
WITNESSES? DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK TO THE ITEM ON SUPPORT,
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD? YES
WE DO, PLEASE. YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
SAY YOU WERE NOT A LEAD WITNESS.
YOU'RE HERE TO JUST INDICATE
SUPPORT. YES. ALL RIGHT. HI.
JACOB ACKEREN, ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS MORNING. I'M WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FAITH LEAGUE. WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE
COME FORWARD? IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD NOW. I SEE NONE, WE'LL
COME BACK. AND I'LL HAND THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR,
WHO WILL SHARE THE REST OF THE
MEETING, I HAD NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENT ON MR. LOW'S BILL. FILE
ITEM 18. VICE CHAIR OCHOA BOGUE.
AND HE HAS PRESENTED. AND, WHILE
YOU'RE GETTING SITUATED, I'LL
JUST TURN IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR A CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
OUR VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I'M HAPPY TO. I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE ITEM WE HAVEN'T HAD. Þ
NØ QUORUMS ESTABLISHED YET. ONE
OF THOSE DAYS WHEN THE TIME
COMES, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK JUST, A
POINT OF ORDER. SOME MEMBER ALSO
HAS FILE ITEM 19. HE'D LIKE TO
PRESENT NEXT. OKAY. WONDERFUL SO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 3034,
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3034 TO ALLOW
AMERICORPS MEMBERS WHO DEDICATE
A YEAR OF VOLUNTEERING TO HAVE
THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF TUITION
WAIVED AS SORT OF A NOVEL IDEA.
BUT OF COURSE, THIS HAS HELPED
TO SUPPORT THE NOTION OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND ALSO SERVICE IN
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEMBER LOW, WE'LL NOW
MOVE, WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3034 HERE IN ROOM
2100? SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB. 3034? HELLO. ANNABELLE
URBINA WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SO SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS NO
COMMENTS. AND WHEN WE HAVE
QUORUM, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. WONDERFUL, WELL, WE DON'T
WE DO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN OPPOSITION, DO
YOU, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES, SURE, CERTAINLY. AND JUST
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS COULD BE
VIEWED AS AN INHERENT COST AND,
OF COURSE, THAT OF ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE YOUNG PEOPLE IS
IMPORTANT, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS IN FULL FAITH THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION WITH
THEIR RESPECTIVE SEGMENTS,
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD?
OKAY. WONDERFUL WELL, IT LOOKS
LIKE WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL
BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO, MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. NEWMAN OKOBOJI.
PRESENT. OKOBOJI. PRESENT.
CORTEZ HERE. CORTEZ. HERE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE.
WILK. PRESENT. WILK. HERE
WONDERFUL. SO WE HAVE,
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. HAPPY TO
MOVE A FILE ITEM 19. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR A FILE NUMBER, ITEM
NUMBER 19, AB 3034. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, OCHOA, BOGH. CORTEZ.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE GLASER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE WILK. HI.
WILK. AYE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OUR
APS AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR. AND WONDERFUL.
AND, WE HAVE MEMBER RAMOS HERE
WITH US TODAY, HE WILL BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER 21, AB
3015. WHEN YOU'RE READY, SIR,
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I WOULD
LIKE TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB
3015 HELPS TO EXPAND COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS, THE MOST
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUP IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. THIS MEASURE WOULD
HELP ENSURE QUALIFIED STUDENTS
ARE NOT DISADVANTAGED BY TRIBAL
LAND BOUNDARIES, AND WOULD AIM
TO EXPAND DIVERSITY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS BY GRANTING
STUDENTS A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES WHOSE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
LAND BORDERS, AND OTHER STATE,
AND WHO LIVE IN THE STATE TO BE
CLASSIFIED AS A RESIDENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TUITION FEES,
ELIMINATES A FINANCIAL BARRIER
AND HELPS THEM PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS MAKE UP LESS THAN 1% OF
ENROLLED STUDENTS, AND WITH THIS
BILL, WE CAN OFFER POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS TO A PROBLEM AND
UPLIFT NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JASON MURPHY, ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
FOR èC STATE GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS. AND WELCOME, SIR.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, JASON MURPHY, ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT WITH THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. WE APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD ON OUR BEHALF, THIS IS
ABOUT SEEKING TO ADDRESS A VERY
NARROW, ISSUE THAT OCCURS,
ALBEIT IMPORTANT ISSUE WHEN
WE'VE GOT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES BORDERING OR CROSSING
OVER, STRADDLING, SO TO SPEAK,
THE BORDER BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND OTHER STATES, SUCH AS NEVADA
AND ARIZONA. WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
ANY TRIBES RIGHT NOW THAT
STRADDLE WITH THE OREGON BORDER.
BUT IN THESE INSTANCES, DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE MEMBERS,
THESE NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS
ARE MEMBERS OF THESE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IF THEY JUST
SO HAPPEN TO LIVE ON THE
ARBITRARY OTHER SIDE OF THEIR
TRIBAL LANDS IN ANOTHER STATE,
THEY ARE NO LONGER OR NOT
ENTITLED TO RESIDENT TUITION. AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE HAD INSTANCES LIKE THIS
COME FORWARD AT OUR CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RECTIFY IT.
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SIR.
AND WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 3015
HERE IN ROOM 2100. PLEASE
PROCEED. THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
MORNING. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. JACOB ARO, ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND PROUD SUPPORT. ANNABELLE
URBINO WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR IN SUPPORT. I URGE
YOU GUYS, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT,
DANIELLA RODRIGUEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 3015.
NOW, WE WILL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
3015. SEEING NONE, WE'LL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTESE, MEMBER RAMOS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL,
THANK YOU. AND, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS AND I ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM 21 AB 3015. RAMOS
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OCHOA I
OKOBOJI. CORTESE I CORTESE I.
GLASER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
. AYE. WILK. AYE. AND WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR. MAY I MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? ABSOLUTELY. WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN.
OKOBOJI. AYE, OKOBOJI. CORTEZ.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK AYE. OKAY SO WE WILL.
WE WILL START OPENING THE ROLL
FOR OUR DIFFERENT BILLS. WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO,
DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR BILL
ITEM NUMBER TWO? I'LL MOVE IT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
CORTESE. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM TWO. AB
1825 MURATSUCHI. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASSES SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NEWMAN, FILE NUMBER
TWO. ONCE AGAIN ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1825 MURATSUCHI.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. CORTEZ
GLAESER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. MURATSUCHI. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 225. Ó. THE BILL. NUMBER
1825.
THE LIBRARY. THE PUBLIC LIBRARY.
1 OR 2. OKAY. WILK. NOT VOTING.
OKAY GO ON TO THE NEXT. OKAY. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 2316 BY MEMBER
GABRIEL. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION BY
MEMBER, SENATOR WILK ON AB 2316?
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OKOBOJI. AYE
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. A CORTEZ. AYE.
GLAZIER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
PUT THAT OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 2508.
BILL, YOU HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WILK. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL, FILE ITEM,
FOR AB 2508 MCCARTY. THE MOTION
IS PASSED TO SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. NEWMAN.
OKOBOJI AYE, AYE. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK. WILK. AYE ALL
RIGHT. PERFECT. WE'LL KEEP THAT.
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, AB 1970 17 BY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. WE NEED A
MOTION. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
I'LL MOVE IT. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AB 1917.
MURATSUCHI MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OKOBOJI. AYE.
OKOBOJI CORTEZ. CORTEZ. GLAZIER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. WILK.
WILK. AYE AND WE'LL KEEP THAT
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX BY MEMBER. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 2226 BY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. WILK MOVES THE BILL
A MOTION BY SENATOR WILK. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
OKOBOJI. NØ. OKOBOJI. NÓ. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. AYE. GLAZIER. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK WILK. AYE
WONDERFUL. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB 1919
BY MEMBER WEBER. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? MOVED BY SENATOR,
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SORRY.
SMALLWOOD SMALLWOOD. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 1919. WEBER.
MOTION IS DUE. PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. OKOBOJI CORTEZ. CORTEZ
AYE. LAZAR. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK OKAY. LET'S DO. OKAY. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW CONTINUE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 3216 BY
MEMBER. HOOVER MOVES THE BILL.
DO YOU HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WILK? MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE.
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. OKOBOJI AYE,
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ. GLAESER.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE WILK.
WILK. AYE WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN
FOR SOME MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW
CONTINUE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2093 BY MEMBER SANTIAGO WILK.
MOVES THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WILK. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. GLAESER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WILK.
WILK. AYE AND WE'LL KEEP THAT
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 14, AB 2507 BY A MEMBER.
FRIEDMAN, WE NEED A MOTION. DO
WE DO WE HAVE A MOTION, WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OCHOA SAID I'M
SORRY. NUMBER 14. YES. THAT
WOULD BE OKAY. NOT VOTING ON
THAT ONE. OKAY. CORTEZ CORTEZ.
AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK. WILK. AYE AND WE'LL KEEP
THAT OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW CONTINUE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2883 BY
MEMBER LO. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
SO MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WILK, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLE. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, OCHOA, BOGH. I OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. GLAESER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. WILK.
WILK. AYE. I WILL KEEP THAT OPEN
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER 19, AB 3030. WHAT'S THAT?
WE ALREADY DID THAT ONE. OH, WE
DID OKAY, SO. OKAY. SO WE'LL
WE'LL CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER 24 AB 3240 BY MEMBER
CALDERON. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL, MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
OKOBOJI. AYE, OKOBOJI. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. GLAESER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE AND WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
, ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE.
WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN THE ROLL
FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
1825. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM TWO. AB
1825. MURATSUCHI THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN, OKOBOJI.
GLASER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I
WILL. OKAY, WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT. SO WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH, THE COMMITTEE. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. WE HAVE
MEMBER BURMAN WHO HAS GRACED US
WITH HIS PRESENCE TO PRESENT
ITEM NUMBER 23, AB 3158. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY, SIR.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS, SUCH AS
FOOD AND HOUSING. AND IN MY
DISTRICT, THE SOARING COSTS OF
LIVING HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR.
TO ADDRESS THIS, WEST VALLEY
MISSION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT FUNDED A COLLEGE
PROMISE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
THROUGH THEIR UNRESTRICTED
GENERAL FUND, BUT THE DISTRICT
WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS. AB 3158 WOULD ALLOW
UNTIL JULY 1ST, 2030. WEST
VALLEY MISSION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT DISTRICT TO PROVIDE
FREE COLLEGE TO THEIR STUDENTS
BY WAIVING TUITION FEES, WHICH
THE DISTRICT IS READY AND ABLE
TO DO WITH THEIR EXISTING LOCAL
FUNDING. THIS WOULD PUT
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL RESOURCES
BACK INTO STUDENT'S POCKETS,
ENSURING THEY DON'T HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING THE EXTRA
CLASS THEY NEED TO GRADUATE OR
WORK. THE EXTRA SHIFT THEY NEED
TO AFFORD GROCERIES OR PAY THEIR
RENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
IS MELANIE HÌ, WHO'S THE WEST
VALLEY COLLEGE STUDENT TRUSTEE
AND A SUMMER INTERN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BERMAN'S DISTRICT OFFICE
AND CAGE STORYTO CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR THE WEST VALLEY MISSION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU, SO GOOD MORNING, SENATORS.
MY NAME IS MELANIE HÌ, AND I
SERVE AS THE STUDENT TRUSTEE AT
WEST VALLEY COLLEGE LOCATED IN
SARATOGA, CALIFORNIA. TODAY, I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE WITH FREE TUITION.
I'M A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT WHO STRUGGLED THROUGH
THE FAFSA PROCESS AND
EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS FOR FREE
TUITION. PRIOR TO FALL SEMESTER,
I PAID $900 OUT OF MY OWN POCKET
FOR MY CLASSES, AND THIS IS NOT
INCLUDING THE COST OF TEXTBOOKS.
I RECEIVED REIMBURSEMENT FOR MY
FIRST SEMESTER'S TUITION SEVERAL
MONTHS LATER. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
MANY STUDENTS FACE DUE TO THE
RISING COST OF LIVING IN THE BAY
AREA. I CAN ATTEST FOR MYSELF
AND ON BEHALF OF MANY STUDENTS
THAT WAITING SEVERAL MONTHS FOR
NEARLY $1,000 IS QUITE PAINFUL
CONSIDERING WE HAVE BILLS TO
PAY. AB 3158 IS A STEP TOWARDS
MAKING EDUCATION MORE ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS IN
THE BAY AREA BY REMOVING
FINANCIAL BARRIERS, THIS BILL
CAN HELP ENSURE THAT MORE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO PURSUE
THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB 3158 FOR THE
FUTURE OF STUDENTS SEEKING
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATORS. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US TODAY. MY NAME IS KATE
SAWYER. LIKE THE MEMBER SAID, I
SERVE AS THE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
THE CHANCELLOR OF WEST VALLEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. OUR
DISTRICT SERVES OVER 16,000
STUDENTS BETWEEN OUR TWO
COLLEGES. AND AS THE MEMBER
ALLUDED TO, SEVERAL STRUGGLE OR
MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE STUDENTS
STRUGGLE WITH BASIC NEEDS,
INSECURITIES, AND MANY DROP OUT
AS A RESULT OF THAT, SO IN
RESPONSE TO THIS, OUR DISTRICT
IS MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO REMOVE
BARRIERS FOR OUR STUDENTS. WE'VE
WAIVED FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING,
PARKING FEES, FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH BASIC NEEDS, AS WELL AS
CHILD CARE FOR OUR PARENTING
STUDENTS. AND IN THIS YEAR,
WE'VE GREATLY EXPANDED OUR
PROMISE PROGRAM TO OFFER TUITION
AND ENROLLMENT FEE WAIVERS FOR
STUDENTS THAT QUALIFY AND THAT
GO THROUGH THE EXPANSIVE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS, WHILE
THIS PROGRAM ENROLLED OVER 5000
STUDENTS IN JUST OUR FIRST MONTH
ALONE, THE PROCESS IS JUST
OPERATIONALLY CUMBERSOME FOR OUR
STAFF TO ADMINISTER AND
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE, AND OFTEN
COMPLEX AND EXPENSIVE FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO APPLY FOR. SO THIS
BILL IS THE NEXT STEP IN THAT
ITERATION FOR REMOVING BARRIERS
FOR OUR STUDENTS. IT DOES NOT
ASK FOR A SINGLE DOLLAR FROM THE
STATE FOR OUR BUDGET. IT SIMPLY
ASKS FOR YOU TO AUTHORIZE OUR
DISTRICT TO DRAFT THE POLICIES
TO FORMALLY WAIVE TUITION AND
ENROLLMENT FEES CODIFIED IN OUR
BOARD POLICIES, TO MAKE THE
EXISTING PROCESS A LOT MORE
EFFICIENT AND MORE EFFICIENT FOR
OUR TAXPAYERS AND OUR STAFF AS
WELL. THE LAST THING I'LL
MENTION IS THAT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE NO IMPACT ON OUR DISTRICT'S
ABILITY TO COMPLY WITH WHAT'S
CALLED THE 50% LAW, WHICH
REQUIRES HALF OF OUR EXPENSES TO
BE SPENT ON INSTRUCTION BASED
SALARY. WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND THIS BILL
WILL REALLY JUST ALLOW US TO,
AGAIN, ADMINISTER AN EXISTING
PROCESS MUCH MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND REALLY FOCUS ON INCREASING
ACCESS FOR OUR MOST IN NEED
STUDENTS. SO FOR THESE REASONS,
WE HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY, WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB 3158 HERE IN
ROOM 2100. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO 3158 AB. 3158
HEARING ROOM 2100. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR CORTEZ. YES, FIRST OF
ALL, I JUST WANTED TO, YOU KNOW,
THANK AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS THIS YEAR. AND I'M
A PROUD COAUTHOR OF THE BILL,
AND IT'S, I CAN ASSURE EVERYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
DISTRICT IS IN EXCELLENT SHAPE
TO EXECUTE ON THIS SHOULD THE
BILL GET SIGNED INTO LAW. THIS
YEAR. SO WITH THAT, I'D BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
SENATOR, A MEMBER BERMAN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? JUST WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
SENATOR CORTEZ ON THIS EFFORT.
APPRECIATE THE DISTRICT FOR
STEPPING UP AND SAYING, HEY, WE
CAN DO THIS. WE WANT TO DO THIS.
WE THINK IT'S BETTER FOR THE
DISTRICT AND IT'S BETTER FOR OUR
STUDENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. I APOLOGIZE, I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT. YEAH, I WANTED TO GET
THIS IN. I WANTED TO DO IT
AFTER. IT'S CLOSE THOUGH. I
WANTED TO ASK, HOW'S THE
INTERNSHIP IN HIS OFFICE? IS
THAT GOING WELL, I'M RINGING IN
AFTERWARDS. GET ME THERE. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY WITH THAT, WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM 23. AB 3158. BERMAN.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
OKOBOJI. HIGH. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE AYE. GONZALEZ. OH
WE'LL. OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY. YOU CAN HEAR THE WHOLE
TIME. SO, WE WILL BE CONTINUING
ON WITH LIFTING CALLS. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
OH, WE'LL BEGIN WITH OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 1825 BY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE
NEWMAN. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE WILK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 2316 BY MEMBER
GABRIEL. MOTION IS Dð. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NO'S, WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE OKAY, I'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR SOME MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 2508 BY
MEMBER MCCARTY, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR EYES AND NO NO'S WITH
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
NEWMAN. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AB 1917 BY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 2226 BY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE AYES AND
ONE NO. WITH THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. NEWMAN. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB
1919 BY MEMBER WEBER. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND NO
NOES. NEWMAN OTOBO GLASER.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. WILK OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
11. AB 3216 BY MEMBER HOOVER.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER 12, AB 2093 BY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
EYES AND NO NOES. NEWMAN
OKOBOJI. GLASER OKAY. I GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. I WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 2507 BY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOES. NEWMAN. OKOBOJI GLASER
2507. CORRECT GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I DID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION? MEMBER. GLASER
. DID YOU NEED ME TO REPEAT?
THAT'S OKAY. I'M ACCOMMODATING.
YES YES. OKAY. SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
18, AB 2883 BY MEMBER LOWE.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASSED A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S, WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 3034 BY
MEMBER LOWE. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOES. NEWMAN. OKOBOJI GLASER.
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
21, AB 3015 BY MEMBER RAMOS.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN. GLASER
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER 23, AB 3158 BY
MEMBER BERMAN. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE AYES AND NO
NOES, WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE WILL CONTINUE, WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ITEM NUMBER
24, AB 3240 BY MEMBER CALDERON.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE OKAY.
AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE COMMITTEE. THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL BE
TAKING A RECESS UNTIL OUR CHAIR
IS ABLE TO RETURN TO THE DAIS.
IS THAT THE ROLL ON? ALL OPEN
MEASURES? MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE PROCEED THROUGH THOSE
MEASURES. OKAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN. EYES
SEVEN ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO.
ITEM ONE. EXCUSE ME. ITEM TWO,
AB 1825. MURATSUCHI MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES. NO NOES. NEWMAN, A NEWMAN.
AYE. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO. FILE NUMBER THREE
AB 2316 GABRIEL. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
EYES. NO NOES. NEWMAN A NEWMAN.
AYE. THAT VOTE IS OUT SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB 2508 MCCARTY. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX EYES, NO NOES. NEWMAN, A
NEWMAN. AYE. THAT MEASURE IS
OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 1917
MURATSUCHI MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS SIX.
EYES, NO. NOSE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NEWMAN I THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO FILED. ITEM
SIX AB 22 2226 MURATSUCHI MOTION
IS DUE PASSED. SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE EYES AND ONE NO.
WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
NEWMAN I MEASURED OUT SIX VOTES
TO ONE, FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 1919
WEBER. MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NOES. NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE.
MEASURES AT FIVE VOTES TO ZERO
FOR ITEM 11 A B 3216. HOOVER
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VOTE IS
SIX EYES. NO NOES NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE. THAT MEASURE IS OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12 AB 2093 SANTIAGO.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
AYES. NO. NOS. NEWMAN A NEWMAN
AYE THAT MEASURES OUT SIX VOTES
TO ZERO FOR ITEM 14 A B 2507.
FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
EYES, NO NOSE NEWMAN A NEWMAN.
AYE. THAT MEASURE IS OUT SIX
VOTES TO ZERO. FILE ITEM 18 AB
2883. LO. MOTIONS DO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
VOTED SIX EYES, NO NOES NEWMAN A
NEWMAN I VOTE THAT MEASURE IS
OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. FILE
ITEM 19 AB 3034. LOU. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE EYES. NO
NOES NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE. AND
THAT MEASURE IS OUT SIX VOTES TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM 21 AB 3015 RAMOS
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX EYES. NO
NOES NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE. AND
THAT MEASURE IS AT SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO. THAT CONCLUDES OH NO.
OH I'M SORRY. THERE'S TWO MORE.
THERE'S ANOTHER SHEET. PLEASE
PROCEED. FILE ITEM 23 AB 3158
BERMAN MOTIONS. DO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX AYES. NO NOES.
NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE. THAT
MEASURES AT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO
A FILE ITEM 24 AB 3240 CALDERON
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VOTES
SIX EYES. NO NOES. NEWMAN I
NEWMAN. AYE AND THAT MEASURE IS
OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. THAT
THAT DOES CONCLUDE, THE CLOSES
OUT THE ROLL. THIS CONCLUDES
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EDUCATION. THANK YOU
TO STAFF ESPECIALLY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ON THIS VERY HECTIC DAY
AND TO THE SERGEANTS. AND WITH
THAT, WE ARE ADJOURNED.